Hosting provided by Hostornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 45. Inside Video Game Programming. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everyone. I upgraded to Windows 10 on my Windows machine.
本节目由Hostornado赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第45期。深入视频游戏编程。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。我在我的Windows机器上升级到了Windows 10。
It's pretty cool. It's a big upgrade. I skipped, I had seven, but I skipped, I guess it's eight. Yep. And everyone skipped nine. Everyone skipped nine because no major company wrote code that could handle Windows 9 without accidentally calling it Windows 98. So they skipped that one, which was smart, and went straight to Windows 10, and I got it. It's pretty cool. But it's not a beta anymore, right? It's actually like out, out?
这真的很酷。这是一个很大的升级。我跳过了，我用的是7，但我跳过了，我想应该是8。没错。而且大家都跳过了9。大家都跳过了9，因为没有哪家大公司编写的代码能处理Windows 9而不意外地将其称为Windows 98。所以他们跳过了那个版本，这很聪明，直接升级到了Windows 10，我也装了。这真的很酷。但它不再是测试版了，对吧？它是真的发布了吗？
Yeah, it's totally out. The only thing that was was hard was um my sound blaster card sound blaster said they weren't gonna create drivers for Windows 10 until October and so but then it turns out somebody created some third-party driver which is probably like leeching my credit card another value I was I say it's probably better but it's probably mining bitcoins yeah it's uh yeah i'm just kidding it's probably it's actually when i ran the setup it is the same i think he just somehow monkey patched the uh the the existing driver to fit windows 10 because the install shield is exactly the same and everything
是的，它完全发布了。唯一困难的是，嗯，我的声卡，Sound Blaster说他们要到十月才会为Windows 10创建驱动程序，但后来发现有人创建了一些第三方驱动程序，这可能是在窃取我的信用卡信息，或者其他什么价值，我开玩笑说这可能更好，但它可能在挖比特币。是的，我开玩笑的，其实当我运行安装程序时，它是一样的，我想他只是以某种方式对现有的驱动程序进行了猴子补丁（monkey patched）以适配Windows 10，因为安装盾（InstallShield）和所有东西完全一样。
uh yeah yeah um yeah yeah yeah i mean it's something about my social and credit card or something but other than that it worked fine i attempted to do it and i got this error it said something happened and then the subtext something happened and then that's it yep and you could close so were you in like a limbo state now like were you your machine no no it was like you know you're supposed to i was supposed to create media for it or whatever uh and so like i i have a feeling that you know you're supposed to wait for your turn and it's not been my turn yet and so but there was like people said like oh you can just go to the download tool and so i just downloaded the download tool and i i think maybe it knows it's not my turn i'm not sure i didn't look into it it. I was just going to try it and see if it worked, and it didn't.
嗯，是的，是的，嗯，是的，是的，是的，我的意思是，这可能涉及我的社交账号和信用卡之类的，但除此之外它运行良好。我尝试安装时遇到了一个错误，它说“发生了一些事情”，然后子文本是“发生了一些事情”，然后就没了。是的，你可以关闭它。所以你现在处于一种不确定的状态吗？你的机器……不，不，就像你知道的，你应该……我本应该为它创建安装介质之类的，所以我有一种感觉，你知道，你应该等待轮到你，但我还没轮到，但有人说，哦，你可以直接去下载工具，所以我下载了下载工具，我想也许它知道还没轮到我，我不确定，我没深究。我只是想试试看它是否有效，结果没成功。
And so then I gave up and figured I'd try it later. I got you. One thing that helped is I had the developer preview, and I was running it in a virtual box, and I was kind of seeing what it was like. And anyone who had the developer preview was had like a priority queue so so on the very first day i was able to get in i didn't i mean i didn't plan on that it's just kind of luck yeah that's cool um yeah yeah so it's pretty cool so did you did you install from
所以我放弃了，打算以后再试。我明白了。有一件事有帮助，那就是我有开发者预览版，我是在虚拟机里运行的，我大概看了看它是什么样子。任何有开发者预览版的人都有优先队列，所以在第一天我就能进入了，我并不是……我的意思是，我没计划那样，这只是运气。是的，那很酷。嗯，是的，是的，所以它真的很酷。那么你是从零开始安装的，还是直接升级的？
scratch or did you just upgrade i installed from scratch because part of it was um i i'd upgraded from like 2000 to xp to 7 on the same hard drive whoa i know it's this ancient 5400 rpm uh you know magnetic hard drive and it's like 100 gigabytes or something something like that 100 or 200 is like it's uber slow and uh i just i know you can migrate to ssd like migrate your windows but i thought you know it's been so long and so patched together that i just wiped it and started over wow um yeah it's actually it was not bad it's quite like liberating to not have just an incredibly cluttered uh you know programs menu and all of that yeah every time i have to clean install i always there's always something missing that takes me forever to remember how i got it installed last time like the non-obvious stuff right like oh here's this program but how did i do that oh
我是从零开始安装的，因为部分原因是，嗯，我在同一块硬盘上从2000升级到XP，再到7。哇，我知道，这是一块古老的5400转磁性硬盘，大概只有100GB左右，或者类似的大小，100或200，它超级慢。我知道你可以迁移到SSD，比如迁移你的Windows，但我心想，这已经过去太久了，而且修补得太多了，所以我直接格式化并重新开始了。哇，嗯，是的，其实这感觉还不错，不用面对一个极其混乱的程序菜单，这真的很让人解脱。是的，每次我进行全新安装时，总会有一些东西缺失，我得花很长时间才能想起上次是怎么安装的，比如那些不明显的设置，对吧？比如，哦，这里有这个程序，但我当时是怎么做的？哦，
there's this plug-in where's that plug-in and then and it just turns into a mess right it's right because your system's just not set up the way you it used to be set up anymore yeah i mean it's gotten a lot easier now because i do so much in the browser and and you have like whether you're using chrome or firefox it syncs and so all of my chrome extensions just kind of magically showed up and everything yeah um i guess my problem is i use my desktop for exclusively things i can't do in the browser typically. Because if I can do it in the browser, I just do it from my iPad or my phone. That's true. That's a good point.
这里有个插件，那个插件在哪？然后它就变成了一团糟，对吧？没错，因为你的系统不再是你以前设置的那样了。是的，我的意思是，现在变得容易多了，因为我大部分工作都在浏览器里完成，无论你用的是Chrome还是Firefox，它都会同步，所以我所有的Chrome扩展程序都神奇地出现了。是的，嗯，我想我的问题是，我使用台式机专门处理那些我通常无法在浏览器中完成的事情。因为如果我能在浏览器中完成，我就直接用iPad或手机做了。那是真的。这是一个很好的观点。
For me, it's basically just Steam. And, oh, one thing about this that was kind of cool. I pointed Steam to where Steam was installed when I was on Windows 7. And I just told Steam to install there. And it detected that. And it said, hey, I see you're installing on top of Steam. So I'm going to figure out what games you've installed and get your OS sort of up to speed with your file system. And it kind of reconciled all of that.
对我来说，基本上就是Steam。哦，关于这一点有一件很酷的事。我把Steam指向了我之前在Windows 7上安装Steam的位置。我只是告诉Steam在那里安装。它检测到了。它说，嘿，我看到你正在覆盖安装Steam。所以我打算弄清楚你安装了哪些游戏，并让你的操作系统与你的文件系统同步。它把所有这些都协调好了。
It was really cool. And saved them a bunch of bandwidth. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, they had a huge incentive to do that's right yeah they huge incentive to do that so uh yeah so that's windows 10 apparently there's bugs um there's this ars technica article talking about um some bugs i haven't hit any of them but but i've literally just used steam oh and audacity to record the show are we recording on windows 10 right now uh not now but uh but i was recording on windows 10 a little earlier so okay uh yeah it worked very good um yeah so that's uh that's
这真的很酷。而且节省了他们大量的带宽。是的，没错。是的，他们有巨大的动力去做这件事，没错，他们有巨大的动力去做这件事。所以，嗯，这就是Windows 10。显然有一些漏洞，有一篇Ars Technica的文章谈到了一些漏洞，我还没遇到过，但我确实只是用了Steam，哦，还有Audacity来录制节目。我们现在是在Windows 10上录音吗？嗯，不是现在，但我在Windows 10上录过一会儿，所以，好的，嗯，是的，它运行得非常好。嗯，所以这就是……
windows 10 another piece of news that's kind of interesting is uh you know there's a lot of this where sort of you you might work at a place and there's a uh you know like a as we're going to talk to some video game professionals later there's you know they i'm sure they have you know a graphics team and uh uh like a graphics engine team artist team maybe they have like a analytics team that's looking at how many people are using we'll have to ask them we haven't said that yet oh stay tuned we have an awesome interview that we're gonna do here in a few minutes that's right that's right well i hope it'll be awesome yeah and so maybe they have like a analytics team that's that's looking at how many people are hitting their website things like that um where i work there's the same thing there's a bunch of different teams. And they all sort of have their own hardware, like their own resources, their own cluster of machines that they use to go off and do work.
Windows 10。另一条比较有趣的新闻是，嗯，你知道，有很多这样的情况，你可能在某个地方工作，有一个……嗯，就像我们稍后要和一些视频游戏专业人士交谈一样，他们肯定有图形团队，图形引擎团队，美术团队，也许他们有分析团队，在观察有多少人在使用……我们得问问他们，我们还没说呢。哦，敬请期待，我们几分钟后会有一个很棒的采访。没错，没错，好吧，我希望它会很棒。是的，所以也许他们有一个分析团队，在观察有多少人在访问他们的网站之类的。嗯，我工作的地方也是一样，有很多不同的团队。他们都有自己的硬件，自己的资源，自己的一组机器，用来完成工作。
It's not very efficient. I mean, if one team isn't using the cluster, their cluster, and the other team needs to do something really important they should be able to use that other team's cluster without like having to ask for permission and things like that that kind of takes forever right so um google's had this thing for a while called borg named after the the star trek um thing but they uh um they recently open sourced I don't think they open sourced the Borg itself like what they have but they made a similar version that like leveraged a lot of that
这效率不高。我的意思是，如果一个团队没有在使用他们的集群，而另一个团队需要做一些非常重要的事情，他们应该能够使用那个团队的集群，而不必请求许可之类的，那太耗时了，对吧？所以，嗯，谷歌有一段时间有一个叫Borg的东西，以《星际迷航》里的东西命名，但他们……嗯，他们最近开源了，我不认为他们开源了Borg本身，就是他们拥有的那个，但他们制作了一个类似的版本，利用了其中的很多东西。
maybe it's like Borg version 2 or something and they open sourced that and it's called Kubernetes we'll give you a link to it in the show notes but it's pretty cool you can set this up on all of your machines company-wide, and you can set up quotas and things like that
也许是Borg 2.0之类的，他们开源了它，叫Kubernetes。我们会在节目笔记中给你提供链接，它非常酷。你可以在公司范围内的所有机器上设置它，你可以设置配额之类的。
and say, okay, this team is guaranteed to have 50 machines, and this other team is guaranteed to have 50 machines. And so if you have a job that can take anywhere from 50 to 100 machines, it'll use all 100 as long as the other team isn't using it. And if the other team comes on, it'll start kicking your guys out and replacing it with that other team's because they have a quota, right? So it does all of that. It's pretty cool. And I'm pretty excited to try it out.
然后说，好的，这个团队保证有50台机器，另一个团队保证有50台机器。所以如果你有一个需要50到100台机器的任务，只要另一个团队没在使用，它就会使用全部100台。如果另一个团队上线了，它就会开始把你的任务踢出去，换上另一个团队的任务，因为他们有配额，对吧？所以它能做到所有这些。这很酷。我很兴奋能尝试一下。
Yeah, this sounds like something I need for my home. I, you know, I run about 40 different computers in my basement and right. No, that's the one that, the one that powers the nuclear submarine that searches for dinosaurs. Is that one?
是的，这听起来像是我家里需要的东西。我，你知道，我在地下室运行了大约40台不同的电脑，没错。不，那是那个，那个为搜索恐龙的核潜艇提供动力的电脑。是那个吗？
Has that one finished yet? That sounds awesome. Is that a book? I just made that up. Speaking of books, it's time for Book of the Show. Book of the Show. My Book of the Show is a relic, but it's quite entertaining. It's The Mythical Man Month.
那个完成了吗？听起来很棒。那是一本书吗？我刚编的。说到书，现在是“本期推荐书目”时间。本期推荐书目。我推荐的书是一本老古董，但非常有趣。它是《人月神话》（The Mythical Man-Month）。
And it's an old book. It's like, what, 1998, I think? 1995. And it's all about sort of project management, software engineering, and sort of how... I mean, he talks about a bunch of different things. I'll just say one thing. One piece of it is they talk about how one person can do a lot because that person can keep a lot in his mind and doesn't really have to document or collaborate and so they could just hold the state in their mind especially when they're doing like a prototype and as soon as you add you know a second or a third person it increases the overhead
这是一本老书。大概是，什么，1998年？1995年。它全是关于项目管理、软件工程，以及如何……我的意思是，他谈论了很多不同的事情。我只说一点。其中一部分是他们谈论一个人如何能做很多事，因为那个人可以把很多东西记在脑子里，不需要真正地记录或协作，所以他们可以把状态保存在脑子里，特别是在做原型的时候。而一旦你增加了一个或第三个人，它就会增加开销，
and causes the productivity to go down and then you eventually like you make it up with you know economies of scale right and i guess at some point you keep going, then it breaks down again. And this thing kind of talks about just project management, how hard it is to estimate schedules and things like that. It's really quite interesting. I won't do it justice by trying to explain it myself. But if you're interested in how software companies get things done you know if you're a type person that's done a lot of side projects and they either kind of don't go anywhere they tend to linger and you kind of think to yourself man like how
并导致生产力下降，然后你最终会通过规模经济来弥补，对吧？我想在某个时候你继续前进，然后它又会崩溃。这本书谈论的只是项目管理，估计进度表有多难之类的。这真的很有趣。我自己解释可能无法体现它的价值。但如果你对软件公司是如何完成工作的感兴趣，你知道，如果你是一个做过很多副项目的人，它们要么没下文，要么往往拖延，你可能会想，天哪，怎么……
like if you have to if you how can you tell someone a year from now there's going to be product x like like how is that possible and uh this sort of explains kind of breaks that down explains how to do that have you read this i think the first few times i saw this reference i always saw it said the mythical man moth and then i thought it was like a like a i don't know like a fiction book or whatever nice like you know loch ness monster the mythical man moth i don't know why but for like several years when i kept seeing it mentioned, I always thought that's what it said. Awesome. Mythical man moth.
如果你必须……你怎么能告诉别人一年后会有产品X？这怎么可能？这本书解释了这一点，分解了它，解释了如何做到这一点。你读过吗？我想前几次我看到这个引用时，我总是看到它写着“神话中的飞蛾人”（Mythical Man Moth），然后我以为它是一本小说之类的。不错，就像尼斯湖水怪，神话中的飞蛾人。我不知道为什么，但好几年里，当我一直看到它被提到时，我总是以为它是那样写的。太棒了。神话中的飞蛾人。
Yeah. Month, man month. Yeah. Anyways, I have not read it. I hear that I should read it, I guess. Yeah. For people who don't know, the man month is basically a month's worth of one person's work. So in other words, you might have eight man months worth of
是的。月，人月。是的。总之，我没读过。我听说我应该读读它，我想。是的。对于不知道的人来说，人月基本上是一个人一个月的工作量。换句话说，你可能有八个人月的工作量，
work but if you have eight people then it gets done in a month so that's sort of where the man in theory that's where the that's where the man month comes from yeah right because it says oh if you had you know 30 people working on it well i guess a man month isn't 30 days but yeah 30 people working on it you could finish it in a day yeah like it the calculus doesn't work that way in reality have you heard that saying uh like this baby's taking too long you know put nine women on it get it done get it conceived get it uh birthed in a month you can have nine babies in nine months with nine people but you can't make one baby in one month with nine people that's right and it's the same with software maybe not the same numbers but okay my book is a fiction
但如果你有八个人，那么它在一个月内就能完成，所以这就是“人月”的由来。是的，没错，因为有人说，哦，如果你有30个人在做它，嗯，我想人月不是30天，但是的，30个人在做它，你可以在一天内完成。是的，现实中的计算不是那样工作的。你听过那句谚语吗？嗯，就像“这个婴儿花的时间太长了，找九个女人来做，一个月内把它生出来”。你可以在九个月内用九个人生九个婴儿，但你不能在一个月内用九个人生一个婴儿。没错，软件也是一样，也许数字不同，但好吧。我的书是一本小说，
book armada by ernest klein you may remember him he's been a previous book of the month author he wrote ready player one which jason you Player One, yes? I thought it was amazing. Yep. Yeah, I was a super big fan. And I also really liked Ready Player One. Armada is also very good. I didn't like it as much as Ready Player One. To be fair, it's not a sequel.
《无敌舰队》（Armada），作者是恩斯特·克莱恩（Ernest Cline）。你可能还记得他，他是我们之前推荐过的书的作者，他写了《头号玩家》（Ready Player One），Jason，你读过《头号玩家》，对吧？我觉得它太棒了。没错。是的，我是超级大粉丝。我也非常喜欢《头号玩家》。《无敌舰队》也非常棒。我没那么喜欢它，不如《头号玩家》。公平地说，它不是续集。
It's a completely just another book. I'm actually glad it wasn't a sequel because I felt like Ready Player One was pretty conclusive. I wasn't really ready to sort of see that storyline continue nope nope it's just another story has nothing really to do i mean it's a similar style obviously same author but a completely different world and uh i find it instead of being themed of like 80s you know stuff it's more like science fiction and science like video games like science fiction video games instead of like 80s video games okay um so that's just more my cup of tea uh and so in some ways that made it like a more fun read for me but in some ways i think it hurt it a little
它完全是另一本书。我其实很高兴它不是续集，因为我觉得《头号玩家》已经很圆满了。我并没有准备好看到那个故事情节继续下去。不，不，它只是另一个故事，真的没什么关系。我的意思是，风格显然相似，作者也一样，但世界完全不同。我发现它不是以80年代的东西为主题，而是更像科幻小说，像视频游戏，是科幻视频游戏，而不是80年代的视频游戏。好的，嗯，所以这更合我的口味。在某些方面，这让它对我来说读起来更有趣，但在某些方面，我认为这反而有点损害了它，
because uh he has lots of references and he would explain them like uh my buddy tells me use the force luke quoting my favorite line from star wars and it's like yeah we got it we know oh yeah that's but when i read it for 80s references i'm not as good and so like i needed it and it was okay but yeah now it's kind of like no i already know that um so i found that part a little bit greeting but well I know nothing about well not nothing but I know by nerd standards I know nothing about science fiction so so this will be good for me I think now when I say science fiction
因为他有很多引用，他会解释它们，比如“我的哥们告诉我，使用原力，卢克”，引用我最喜欢的《星球大战》台词，就像是，是的，我们懂，我们知道。哦，是的，那是……但当我读80年代的引用时，我没那么擅长，所以我需要它，这还可以。但现在感觉就像，不，我已经知道了。所以我发现那部分有点令人厌烦。好吧，我对科幻小说一无所知，或者说不是一无所知，但以书呆子的标准来看，我什么都不知道，所以这对我有好处。我想，现在当我提到科幻小说时，
this isn't like hard science fiction this is like Star Wars Star Trek even that yeah I'm very weak last I know the I don't know anything. Okay. Anyways, I definitely enjoyed it. It was a fun read. Towards the end, thankfully, it seemed like I didn't notice him saying it as much.
这不是那种硬科幻，这是像《星球大战》、《星际迷航》那样的。即使是那样，我也很弱。我什么都不知道。好吧。总之，我绝对很喜欢它。这是一本有趣的读物。谢天谢地，到最后，我似乎没注意到他那么频繁地解释了。
So it was easy. I didn't feel like I was getting bombarded. And I actually listened to this on Audible as I do lots of my reading because I I call it reading, but it's listening because I'm stuck in my car for a long commute each day and If you would like to get a book from audible they do help sponsor our podcast and you can go to
所以这很容易。我没觉得被轰炸。我其实是在Audible上听这本书的，就像我读很多书一样，因为我称之为阅读，但其实是听，因为我每天上下班路上都被困在车里。如果你想从Audible获得一本书，他们确实赞助了我们的播客，你可以去
www.audibletrial.com programming throw down all one word all lowercase and You can get a free book for a month and then you can cancel it and you can keep the book um and i have a subscription for audible that i just pay for and i really enjoy it and i've canceled it in the past when i had too many books to read and you get to keep all those books uh and then when you pick it back up again you can get more awesome very cool so i like audible and if you have a commute it definitely helps the commute be a little less tedious yeah definitely a little us first a little less us first but then after you listen to us go i thought they probably when we publish this podcast they sit at their computer
www.audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，全部小写，连在一起。你可以免费获得一个月的书，然后你可以取消订阅，书还是你的。嗯，我有一个Audible订阅，我一直在付费，我真的很喜欢它。我过去在书太多读不完的时候取消过，你依然可以保留所有那些书。当你重新订阅时，你可以获得更多。太棒了，非常酷。所以我喜欢Audible，如果你有通勤时间，它绝对能让通勤不那么枯燥。是的，绝对。
and listen to it until it's done and then they go to work yeah i mean you can't you can't uh you know record like take notes on the book of the show if you're driving that's true but to be fair this will be posted on our website later right exactly cool uh okay so it's tool of the show tool of the show so that's almost my tool of the show so that's almost my tool the show is um so is i actually posted about this on the the uh actually i posted on my personal g plus uh but it's called photopia and it's a interactive fiction um and if you don't know what that is um it's basically um choose your own adventure yeah it's choose your own adventure but instead of a multiple choice at every step it's these two word imperative sentences and the state machine is much much larger so you know in other words you could put things like go north uh you know get torch um things like that open door exactly zork is a is an interactive fiction
嗯，我想当我们发布这个播客时，他们坐在电脑前听完它，然后去上班。是的，我的意思是，如果你在开车，你不能做笔记。那是真的。但公平地说，这稍后会发布在我们的网站上，对吧？没错。酷。好的，那么是“本期工具”时间。本期工具。所以这几乎是我的工具。本期工具是……嗯，我其实在我的个人G+上发过这个，但它叫Photopia，它是一个互动小说。如果你不知道那是什么，嗯，它基本上是“选择你自己的冒险”。是的，它是选择你自己的冒险，但不是每一步都有多项选择，而是这些双词祈使句，状态机要大得多。所以，你知道，换句话说，你可以输入像“向北走”、“拿火把”之类的东西。打开门，没错。Zork就是一个互动小说。
and so um i generally hate interactive fiction because um the puzzles really frustrate me and because it's so open-ended like there's i mean any verb you can think of may be what you need to do to that torch to get to the next room. So you're like kick torch, drop torch. And it's just you end up like having to go and like read a tutorial or something like that. That's called cheating. Yeah, you end up having to cheat. But I love the idea of using the interactivity to delay the story and to sort of add a human element to the story. And I mean, that's basically what Final Fantasy does. Right.
所以，嗯，我通常讨厌互动小说，因为谜题真的让我很沮丧，而且因为它太开放了，我的意思是，任何你能想到的动词都可能是你需要对那个火把做的事情，才能进入下一个房间。所以你会像“踢火把”、“扔火把”。你最终不得不去读教程之类的。那叫作弊。是的，你最终不得不作弊。但我喜欢利用互动性来推迟故事，并为故事增加一种人性元素。我的意思是，这基本上就是《最终幻想》所做的。没错。
I mean, Final Fantasy, I mean, in my opinion, is a movie that has sort of these game elements in between to kind of stitch everything together and like to kind of keep you excited right but there are real choices too that do influence the story yeah i mean that's true it's an oversimplification but um so this so this interactive fiction photopia there is not that much puzzle solving and there's also a a help built in you can just type help and you or maybe it's hint and you get a hint You can just type help, or maybe it's hint, and you get a hint. Can you just type give answer? Well, if you type hint, you get a pretty good hint. Okay, go end?
我的意思是，《最终幻想》，在我看来，是一部电影，中间穿插了这些游戏元素，把一切缝合在一起，让你保持兴奋。但也有真正的选择会影响故事。是的，我的意思是，那是真的，这是一种过度简化。但嗯，所以这个互动小说Photopia，没有那么多解谜，而且它内置了帮助，你可以直接输入“help”，或者也许是“hint”，你会得到一个提示。你可以直接输入“help”，或者也许是“hint”，你会得到一个提示。你可以直接输入“给出答案”吗？嗯，如果你输入“hint”，你会得到一个很好的提示。好的，结束了吗？
Go end. End game. The narrative is extremely compelling. Basically, it's temporally nonlinear. And so you start off kind of in the middle and it's called photopia because there's different colors representing the different actors in the scene uh whose perspective you're you're in and uh it actually gets a little more complicated than that with the colors but at any rate and so you're sort of like flow you know that
结束。结局。叙事非常引人入胜。基本上，它是时间非线性的。所以你开始时有点在中间，它之所以叫Photopia，是因为有不同的颜色代表场景中不同的演员，你处于他们的视角。嗯，颜色方面其实比那更复杂一点。但无论如何，所以你就像……你知道，
you're not flowing linearly through time because you're experiencing things just in very like you experience someone as a teenager and they experience their birth and it's just kind of like but but it all kind of stitches together and for me i kind of figured out all these disparate characters i figured it figured out sort of how it came together about 70 of the way through and it was just kind of mind blowing like all of a sudden it kind of hit me what was going on so definitely check that out you can get it
你不是线性地流过时间，因为你只是在体验事物，就像你体验某人作为青少年，然后体验他们的出生，这有点像……但这一切都缝合在一起。对我来说，我弄清楚了所有这些不同的角色，我在70%的时候弄清楚了它是如何结合在一起的，这简直让人大开眼界。突然间，我明白了发生了什么。所以一定要去看看，你可以得到它。
on there's a web version there's iOS Android it's all free which is pretty cool so check that out also Benz Magyar posted and he had another interactive fiction called Choice of Robots
有一个网页版，有iOS版，Android版，都是免费的，这很酷。所以去看看吧。另外，Benz Magyar发布了另一个互动小说，叫《机器人选择》（Choice of Robots）。
this one's literally a choose your own adventure but some of the choices you make cause your stats to go up in different ways and that kind of limits or expands in other words the choices you can make later on so in other words
这个真的是“选择你自己的冒险”，但你做的一些选择会导致你的属性以不同的方式上升，这在某种程度上限制或扩展了你以后可以做的选择。换句话说，
if you make a bunch of choices of type x it'll be harder to choose choices of type y and so it kind of like guides your character in a sense um but these are kind of fun they're usually pretty short and uh and uh short and sweet and photopia is definitely a must photopia is like the beatles of interactive fiction like what the beatles are to music so i mean everyone everyone will love this we'll love photopia so it's the uber of interactive fiction that's right that's right they're the uh yeah they're the unicorn the netflix yeah okay my kid my tool is not a tool but a game surprise like almost every week and And that is Don't Starve on iOS.
如果你做了很多X类型的选择，以后就很难选择Y类型的选择。所以它在某种意义上引导你的角色。嗯，这些都很有趣，通常很短，而且……短小精悍。Photopia绝对是必玩的。Photopia就像互动小说界的披头士乐队，就像披头士对音乐的意义一样。所以我的意思是，每个人都会喜欢这个，我们都会喜欢Photopia。所以它是互动小说界的Uber。没错，没错，他们是独角兽，Netflix。好的，我的工具不是工具，而是游戏，惊喜，几乎每周都有。那就是iOS上的《饥荒》（Don't Starve）。
Is this good? I've seen this on Steam for PC. Yeah, so I guess it's been out for like computers. And I think there's even a version for the PSP, maybe PlayStation. I don't know if it's on the Xbox. But Don't Starve, it's kind of a roguelike, except that, you know, it's fully animated in a very uh specific style i guess it might or might not be your style but um you run around kind of a procedurally generated world in 2d and you collect
这个好吗？我在PC上的Steam上见过它。是的，所以我猜它已经在电脑上发布了。我想甚至还有PSP版本，也许是PlayStation。我不知道Xbox上有没有。但《饥荒》，它有点像Roguelike游戏，除了，你知道，它是以一种非常特定的风格完全动画化的。我想它可能适合也可能不适合你的风格，但嗯，你在一个二维的程序生成世界里跑来跑去，你收集
stuff and you try to craft things and you try to survive and like kind of everything goes against you your guy gets hungry and you need to make sure to provide him enough food not everything is nice to you in the world um and so i've been playing i've really enjoyed it um cool i i stopped playing it for a little while because i kind of got like frustrated like i did something i guess it was my fault but then like you know i ended up like dying at a part that i didn't think i should have died at and then i got kind of mad and so i've been playing it but i will go back to it um the game was just doing its part and being harsh, which is a little bit of a harsh game.
东西，你尝试制作物品，你尝试生存，就像一切都与你作对。你的角色会饿，你需要确保为他提供足够的食物。世界上并非一切都对你友好。所以，我一直在玩，我真的很喜欢它。酷。我停了一段时间，因为我有点沮丧，就像我做了一些事，我猜是我的错，但后来，你知道，我最终死在了一个我不认为我应该死的地方，然后我有点生气。所以我一直在玩，但我会回去玩的。游戏只是在尽它的职责，表现得很严酷，这是一款有点严酷的游戏。
I think a lot of games baby us these days, and it's really hard to lose, and you just expect to be able to do whatever and not die. Your guy can get shot 50 times before he has to respawn. Yeah, I do think that a lot of games that have quick save and quick load, as soon as you introduce quick save, quick load, then you don't have to worry about replayability. You figure the person is never going to have to play the beginning of the game
我认为现在很多游戏都在溺爱我们，很难输掉，你只是期望能够做任何事情而不死。你的角色可以在重生前被射中50次。是的，我确实认为很多有快速保存和快速加载的游戏，一旦你引入了快速保存和快速加载，你就不必担心重玩性了。你认为玩家永远不必玩游戏的开头，
more than once if they don't want to. And so it can cause game designers, I think, to be a little lazy. Whereas if you make Mario, you better make world 1-1 pretty cool otherwise that's gonna be 90 of of what people play you know what i mean yep cool yeah i'll check that out i love roguelikes so that sounds that sounds awesome all right and uh now we're about to have an interview and that's right that's right we're about to have an interview. That's right. That's right. We're going to interview Dave, who works for Naughty Dog.
除非他们想。所以这可能会导致游戏设计师变得有点懒惰。而如果你制作《马里奥》，你最好把1-1关卡做得非常酷，否则那将是人们玩90%的内容。你知道我的意思吗？没错。酷，是的，我会去看看。我喜欢Roguelike游戏，所以这听起来很棒。好的，现在我们要进行采访了。没错，没错，我们要进行采访了。没错，没错。我们要采访Dave，他在顽皮狗（Naughty Dog）工作。
And we're going to... Interview Florent, who works for Ubisoft. That's right. And they are actual game developers. So we talked about game development, game programming in the past, but we got an opportunity to interview people who are actually there doing it. And that was definitely very exciting for us. And I think you'll find it.
我们要采访Florent，他在育碧（Ubisoft）工作。没错。他们是真正的游戏开发者。所以我们过去谈论过游戏开发、游戏编程，但我们有机会采访那些真正身处其中并从事这项工作的人。这对我们来说绝对非常令人兴奋。我想你会发现的。
We'll all find it pretty awesome. All right. So we'll be back in just a second. Hey, everyone. We have a very special show today. We're actually talking about industry game programming, and we have two industry game programming experts. We have Dave Smith, who's a tools programmer at Naughty Dog,
我们都会觉得它很棒。好的。所以我们一会儿就回来。嘿，大家好。我们今天有一个非常特别的节目。我们实际上是在谈论行业游戏编程，我们有两位行业游戏编程专家。我们有Dave Smith，他是顽皮狗的工具程序员，
and we have Florent. How do you pronounce your last name? Devisheval. Devisheval? Yep. Cool. Florent Devisheval is a tools programmer at Ubisoft. And I'm sure you guys know about Naughty Dog and Ubisoft. They're also going to kind of explain those companies if
我们有Florent。你的姓怎么发音？Devisheval。Devisheval？没错。酷。Florent Devisheval是育碧的工具程序员。我相信你们都知道顽皮狗和育碧。如果你们不知道，他们也会解释这些公司，
you don't, which is fine. And so we're going to kind of talk about what it's like to work at a real game studio. I'm sure a lot of you out there are very interested. So just to get started, kind of, you know, Florent and Dave, tell us a little bit about your history, how you got involved in games programming, and things like that. FLORENT RICARDO BOUCHARD- All right. Hi, everyone. So I've always wanted to do video games, actually.
这没关系。所以我们要谈谈在真正的游戏工作室工作是什么感觉。我相信你们很多人都非常感兴趣。所以刚开始，Florent和Dave，告诉我们一点你们的历史，你们是如何参与游戏编程的，以及类似的事情。FLORENT RICARDO BOUCHARD- 好的。大家好。所以，我一直想做视频游戏，其实。
So once I graduated from the university, I simply started to look for a job in the video game industry. I didn't find a job at first, so I went to work as a software developer. I did that for a year, and then after that, Ubisoft was looking for a tools programmer. I applied, and I got hired. So I worked on Assassin's Creed and now I'm working on The Division.
所以一旦我从大学毕业，我就开始寻找视频游戏行业的工作。起初我没找到工作，所以我去做了软件开发人员。我做了那一年，然后之后，育碧正在寻找工具程序员。我申请了，我被录用了。所以我参与了《刺客信条》，现在我正在做《全境封锁》。
And how long have you been there? Three years. Cool. And yeah, so what about Dave? Dave. Hi, this is Dave. So I've worked at Naughty Dog about six years and before that I worked at a few startups in San Francisco and then I was an independent consultant for a while. I like flow, I got out of school, I really wanted to make games but at the time it was 1999 and I was seduced by the hope hope of becoming rich in san francisco at a software startup and if you know anything about the software market around that time i got there just in time to see it all crash so i never got rich um did you did you go to any of these i heard crazy stories
你在那里待了多久？三年。酷。是的，那么Dave呢？Dave。嗨，我是Dave。我在顽皮狗工作了大约六年，在那之前我在旧金山的一些初创公司工作，然后我做了一段时间的独立顾问。我像Florent一样，我毕业后，真的很想做游戏，但当时是1999年，我被在旧金山的软件初创公司变得富有这种希望所诱惑。如果你了解那个时期的软件市场，我赶到那里时正好看到它全部崩溃。所以我从来没变富。嗯，你去过这些地方吗？我听过疯狂的故事，
about you know like pets.com bought this entire hotel and anyone can just stay here and just kind of crazy stories about the dot com boom do you did you experience any of that i there's one story i have that is crazy to me i worked for a company that was incubated by a startup incubator which is basically just a big company with a bunch of investment funds that has been given the edict to go spawn smaller companies that hopefully will go into the next pets.com, I guess. And so I think they had an endowment of like a billion dollars, of which the company I work for had a seed of some tiny percentage.
关于，你知道，比如Pets.com买下了整个酒店，任何人都可以住在这里，还有关于互联网泡沫的疯狂故事。你经历过这些吗？我有一个故事对我来说很疯狂。我为一家公司工作，它是由一家初创孵化器孵化的，这基本上就是一家拥有大量投资基金的大公司，被赋予了去催生更小公司的使命，希望它们能成为下一个Pets.com，我想。所以我想他们有大约十亿美元的捐赠，其中我工作的公司占了很小的一部分。
But of that billion dollars, they spent something like $200 or $500 million of it buying a big old building in downtown San Francisco, which seems just like the most flagrant, wasteful way to spend your money if you're trying to work as a startup incubator. But other than that, I don't really know a lot of truly crazy startup stories. All right, cool. Fair enough.
但在那十亿美元中，他们花了大约2亿或5亿美元在旧金山市中心买了一栋大楼，如果你试图作为初创孵化器工作，这看起来简直是最公然、最浪费的钱的方式。但除此之外，我真的不知道太多真正疯狂的初创公司故事。好的，酷。有道理。
Yeah, so after I bounced around a few startups, I decided to become an independent consultant. I did that for a few years, but always still wanted to make games. So I just started applying to different studios and studying the things that I thought I needed to learn to do that. And eventually wound up here at Naughty Dog. Cool, cool. Very awesome. So what are sort of the different roles? I mean, imagine, you know, a game requires a lot of different people to kind of come together. You know, obviously people know about these really old games like Pitfall and things like that that were made by one person, but that's sort of more of like a relic right and nowadays you know a lot of uh there's a lot of people involved in making a game and so what are sort of these different people that you have to work with
是的，所以在几家初创公司转了一圈后，我决定成为一名独立顾问。我做了几年，但仍然想做游戏。所以我开始向不同的工作室申请，并学习我认为我需要学习的东西来做到这一点。最终来到了顽皮狗。酷，酷。非常棒。那么有哪些不同的角色呢？我的意思是，想象一下，你知道，一个游戏需要很多人聚在一起。你知道，显然人们知道像《Pitfall》这样非常古老的游戏，它们是由一个人制作的，但那更像是一个遗迹，对吧？如今，你知道，有很多……有很多参与制作游戏的人。所以你们必须与哪些不同的人合作？
and so what are the the requirements or the expertise that each of them bring to the table yeah you you definitely can't make a game alone anymore well you can but uh if you want to make triple a games it's kind of hard to do it on your own. Because obviously you need artists, so people who will basically make all the 3D assets or 2D assets that you need, so the meshes, the textures. You might also need animators, so people who will make animations for your characters and for your AI agents. The designers are also really, really important. They are basically building the rules of your game. And also they are doing good level design is what makes a game fun compared to a game that won't be fun. You have also programmers, of course.
那么他们每个人带来的要求或专业知识是什么？是的，你绝对不能再独自制作游戏了。好吧，你可以，但如果你想制作3A级游戏，独自完成有点难。因为显然你需要艺术家，也就是基本上制作你所需的所有3D资产或2D资产的人，比如网格、纹理。你可能还需要动画师，也就是为你的角色和AI代理制作动画的人。设计师也非常、非常重要。他们基本上是在构建你的游戏规则。而且，好的关卡设计是让游戏变得有趣的关键，相比于不好玩的游戏。当然，你还有程序员。
Well, you have a lot of different types of programming in a AAA studio, so of course you've got tools. But you have a lot like you can have graphics engineers, you can have gameplay engineers, network, UI, QA. So yeah, you can do a lot of things in programming. One thing also that is really important is all the testers and the QA team. Basically, they are here to make sure that the level of quality for the game is reached, like the game is really what it needs to be. Yeah. I don't know, Dave. What do you think about it? Yeah, yeah.
嗯，在3A工作室里有很多不同类型的编程，所以当然你有工具。但你有很多，比如你可以有图形工程师、游戏性工程师、网络、UI、QA。所以是的，你可以在编程中做很多事情。还有一件非常重要的事情是所有的测试人员和QA团队。基本上，他们在这里是为了确保达到游戏的质量水平，比如游戏确实是它需要成为的样子。是的。我不知道，Dave。你怎么看？是的，是的。
I think that's a pretty good list. I think there are some roles that people tend to overlook when they're thinking about game production, just because they're not part of the core production process. So I think the people you mentioned are the army that goes into deployment and builds most of the game. But then there's also a lot of people in pre-production like the writers and the concept artists and designers who do the early work to figure out what the game is going to be about and what it's going to look like and the story structure for the game if you have a narrative game. And then on the flip side, at the end of the cycle there's a lot of people in QA like you
我认为这是一个很好的列表。我认为当人们考虑游戏制作时，往往会忽略一些角色，仅仅因为他们不是核心制作过程的一部分。所以我认为你提到的人是参与部署并构建大部分游戏的军队。但也有很多在前期制作中的人，比如编剧、概念艺术家和设计师，他们做早期的工作来弄清楚游戏的内容、外观，以及如果你有叙事游戏的话，游戏的故事情节结构。然后在另一端，在周期结束时，有很多QA人员，像你
mentioned to make sure everything's going to work, but also who do localization to translate the game to 25 different languages and who do release management and marketing. And then also there's usually a lot of producers who manage the time of the individuals involved with production. Although I mentioned that knowing that Naughty Dog, unlike most studios, has very few producers. We have a couple of producers from Sony and that's all. Whereas I think most studios have, the producers are much
提到的那样，确保一切都能正常工作，但也有进行本地化的人，将游戏翻译成25种不同的语言，还有负责发布管理和市场营销的人。而且通常还有很多制作人，他们管理参与制作的个人的时间。虽然我提到这一点时知道，顽皮狗与大多数工作室不同，几乎没有制作人。我们有几个来自索尼的制作人，仅此而已。而我认为大多数工作室，制作人参与制作的程度要高得多。
more involved in production. Yeah, I think one thing interesting with video games is that whatever you're into, you can practically apply it to video games. Like if you are into architecture, well, you can build levels using your architecture skills. If you are into writing architecture, well, you can build levels using your architecture skills. If you are into writing stories, well, you can basically write stories for video games. So whatever you like to do, I'm pretty sure there is a field where you can fit in. What's the mobility like between different roles? So most people listening to the podcast are, you know, kind of coders at some level.
是的，我认为视频游戏有趣的一点是，无论你对什么感兴趣，你几乎都可以将其应用到视频游戏中。比如如果你对建筑感兴趣，嗯，你可以利用你的建筑技能来构建关卡。如果你对写作感兴趣，嗯，你可以基本上为视频游戏写故事。所以无论你喜欢做什么，我敢肯定有一个领域适合你。不同角色之间的流动性如何？所以大多数听播客的人，你知道，在某种程度上都是程序员。
If you're working on, say, tools programming, how likely it is over the course of your career that you'd also maybe do like graphics engine work or, you know, other kinds of coding roles than just tools programming? Or is it people kind of have their thing and that's what they tend to stay with? Well, I would say it depends on the company you're working on. Maybe some companies, if you're a tools programmer, you're going to stay a tools programmer. At Ubisoft, actually, you can change if you're a tools programmer and you want to change the gameplay. And of course, if there is an opening for that role,
如果你在做，比如工具编程，在你的职业生涯中，你也有可能做图形引擎工作，或者，你知道，除了工具编程之外的其他编程角色吗？还是说人们有他们擅长的东西，然后他们倾向于坚持下去？嗯，我会说这取决于你工作的公司。也许有些公司，如果你是工具程序员，你就会一直做工具程序员。在育碧，其实如果你是工具程序员，你想改变游戏性，是可以的。当然，如果那个角色有空缺，
you can do that. But I think it also depends on what you want to do. Because basically, of course, if you've been doing, I don't know, graphics programming for 10 years and then you're applying to another company to make network programming, they might wonder why you're doing that. Or, you know, they might say, okay, but you're so good with graphics. We want to keep you into graphics. So, yeah, you can definitely change your role, change your domain.
你可以那样做。但我认为这也取决于你想做什么。因为基本上，当然，如果你已经做了，我不知道，图形编程10年了，然后你申请另一家公司做网络编程，他们可能会怀疑你为什么要那样做。或者，你知道，他们可能会说，好的，但你图形方面太棒了。我们想让你留在图形领域。所以，是的，你绝对可以改变你的角色，改变你的领域。
But it's basically up to you. Cool. Oh, go ahead. I was just going to say my experience is similar in that uh it's definitely up to you and it depends a lot on the studio and the people you're working with but uh you know just like in most disciplines people are always desperate for capable individuals so if you want to transition to a different role the best way to do that is just to be excellent at the role you're looking to move into. But at the same time, game companies are trying really hard to push a product out the door,
但这基本上取决于你自己。酷。哦，请说。我只是想说我的经验也类似，嗯，这绝对取决于你自己，而且很大程度上取决于工作室和你一起工作的人。但嗯，你知道，就像大多数学科一样，人们总是渴望有能力的人，所以如果你想转型到不同的角色，最好的方法就是在你想要转入的角色上表现出色。但与此同时，游戏公司正在非常努力地推动产品上市，
so that puts a lot of obstacles in the way of making that transition from one role to another, just because once you become an expert in a specific domain, the company will definitely need you to produce in that domain because your job exists because they have a need in that role. So that makes it difficult to extract yourself from stuff that you're already an expert at doing. And to be fair, that's like all companies. For people who haven't worked a long time, that often is the case. This is like an epic paradox that has probably been around since the beginning of time, or at least the beginning of modern civilization. But yeah,
这在从一个角色转换到另一个角色的过程中设置了很多障碍，仅仅是因为一旦你成为特定领域的专家，公司肯定需要你在该领域产出，因为你的工作存在就是因为他们对该角色有需求。所以这使得你很难从自己已经是专家的工作中抽身出来。平心而论，所有公司都是这样。对于工作时间不长的人来说，情况往往如此。这就像一个史诗般的悖论，可能从时间之初，或者至少从现代文明之初就存在了。但是，是的，
it's just, you know, you want to specialize and, you know, by doing something, you get better at that thing. But at the same time, through being sort of eclectic,
这只是，你知道，你想专业化，而且，你知道，通过做某件事，你会在这件事上变得更好。但与此同时，通过变得有点不拘一格，
like if you look at amazing discoveries and inventions, they're almost always through someone taking one idea and applying it to a different field. And so, and in general, people don't, a lot of people don't like repetition. And so you're sort of, it's this paradoxical thing where, you know, you get this positive reinforcement loop from doing the thing you're good at over and over again, but then you also kind of need to keep changing it up. And so you hear a lot of these debates in any industry about open versus closed allocation and things like that. And I think it's pretty cool.
就像如果你看看那些惊人的发现和发明，它们几乎总是通过某人采用一个想法并将其应用于不同的领域而产生的。所以，总的来说，人们不喜欢重复。所以这是一种悖论，你知道，你从一遍又一遍地做你擅长的事情中获得了这种正强化循环，但你同时也需要不断地改变它。所以你在任何行业都会听到很多关于开放式与封闭式分配之类的争论。我觉得这很酷。
It sounds like the games industry is one of those places where you can kind of move around a little bit and still kind of get to experience a lot of different areas in the same company well i think that's why it's cool when you're doing tools actually because you're seeing so many different things that uh there is no routine it's never boring so you you might not want to change of job actually yeah it makes sense makes sense um cool so you know a lot of people you know maybe are in high school or in university or have have been through a computer science degree and so at one point everyone kind of thought i'm going to
听起来游戏行业是那种你可以四处走动，仍然可以在同一家公司体验许多不同领域的地方。嗯，我认为这就是为什么当你做工具时很酷，因为你看到了这么多不同的东西，呃，没有常规，它永远不会无聊，所以你可能实际上不想换工作。是的，这很有道理，很有道理。嗯，酷，所以你知道很多人，你知道，可能在高中或大学，或者已经完成了计算机科学学位，所以每个人在某个时候都想过我要
make a cool game or maybe everyone just made tic-tac-toe at one point at least once everyone has kind of done that at one point whether it's for a course or for fun or something like that and so people have made like you know pac-man clones and things like that and sort of their uh you know basement or garage or what have you and so someone who sort of has had that experience of just kind of making a game for fun what's the difference between that and actually kind of making a professional game that turns into something that you see on the shelves? Well, the main thing would be that if you are making an indie game,
做一个很酷的游戏，或者也许每个人在某个时候至少做过一次井字棋，每个人在某个时候都做过，无论是为了课程还是为了好玩之类的。所以人们制作了像，你知道，吃豆人克隆版之类的东西，在他们的，呃，你知道，地下室或车库里，或者其他什么地方。所以一个有那种为了好玩而制作游戏经验的人，这和真正制作一个变成你在货架上看到的东西的专业游戏有什么区别？嗯，主要的一点是，如果你在制作独立游戏，
you will do a lot of different things. You will have to work on 3D assets, on sounds, on menus, on programming, on the design. You will have to work on everything. But when you are making a AAA game, you will work on your specific system. You might only work on this little part of the game. When you're doing an indie game, you will work basically on almost everything. Yeah. Yeah, I think that's definitely true. I mean it's a lot more highly specialized.
你会做很多不同的事情。你必须处理3D资产、声音、菜单、编程、设计。你必须处理所有事情。但当你制作3A游戏时，你将处理你的特定系统。你可能只处理游戏中的这一小部分。当你做独立游戏时，你基本上会处理几乎所有事情。是的。是的，我认为这绝对是真的。我的意思是它更加高度专业化。
I used to, before I became a professional I made games myself all the time and you did get to work on every aspect of the game. Whereas once you're professionally employed you tend to find a specific niche where you can be productive and uh you you learn that niche very well and a lot of the other things don't necessarily come on your table that often um but on the other hand uh i'm trying to think i had something else to say about that but i can't remember what it was. And also, I remember you guys talking about this. I'm touching back on something that you mentioned a second ago, which is that I think a lot of programmers did come from a background where they made games or worked on games.
在成为专业人士之前，我一直自己制作游戏，你确实可以处理游戏的各个方面。而一旦你被专业聘用，你往往会找到一个特定的利基市场，在那里你可以发挥作用，呃，你非常了解那个利基市场，而许多其他事情不一定会经常出现在你的桌面上。嗯，但另一方面，呃，我在想，关于这一点我还有别的话要说，但我记不起是什么了。而且，我记得你们谈论过这个。我刚才提到了你刚才提到的事情，那就是我认为很多程序员确实来自他们制作游戏或从事游戏工作的背景。
I know you talked about that on one of your shows recently. And I was trying to think how I got started. And actually, my very first program was a game that I wrote in longhand on like a yellow spiral notebook. It was a choose-your-own-adventure game I wrote in BASIC and transcribed onto a computer. And obviously, that was a terrible way to develop the program. It didn't work at all. But yeah, from the very beginning, it was always games that was driving me to become a programmer. And I really do wonder what percentage of programmers got into this field because they wanted to make games yeah i think
我知道你最近在你的一个节目中谈到了这一点。我一直在想我是怎么开始的。实际上，我的第一个程序是我用黄色螺旋笔记本手写的一个游戏。那是一个我用BASIC编写并转录到计算机上的“选择你自己的冒险”游戏。显然，那是一种糟糕的开发程序的方式。它根本无法工作。但是，是的，从一开始，总是游戏在驱动我成为一名程序员。我真的很想知道有多少比例的程序员进入这个领域是因为他们想制作游戏。是的，我想
it's it's pretty huge just from i i asked us this to a lot of people and uh i would say i would not know if it's the majority but it might be you know yeah more the majority of people out there um got into it from wanting to make games i my experience with making games i always ended up you know i mean one of the things is when you make a game by yourself you really have no mentor um no one with experience telling you um what's going on so you have to kind of learn everything the hard way um i i had these grandiose visions of oh it's as complex as civilization but has this amazing narrative that's generated automatically through an artificial intelligence and like you end up with you know an armature
这非常巨大，仅仅从我问过很多人这一点来看，呃，我会说我不知道这是否是大多数，但它可能是，你知道，是的，更多的人，呃，是因为想制作游戏而进入这个行业的。我制作游戏的经验是，我总是以，你知道，我的意思是，当你自己制作游戏时，你真的没有导师，呃，没有有经验的人告诉你，呃，发生了什么，所以你必须以困难的方式学习一切，呃，我有这些宏大的愿景，哦，它和文明一样复杂，但有这种通过人工智能自动生成的惊人叙事，就像你最终得到，你知道，一个电枢
walking like after two years you have like a stick figure in 3d that can walk yeah i think that's interesting because you it's actually a problem of scope. When you're working on an indie game, you cannot, well, you might not be able to have the same scope as a big production. So you need to be way more pragmatic. You need to go straight to the point.
走着，两年后你就有了一个可以行走的3D火柴人。是的，我认为这很有趣，因为这实际上是一个范围问题。当你制作独立游戏时，你不能，嗯，你可能无法拥有与大型制作相同的范围。所以你需要更加务实。你需要直奔主题。
Yeah, that's right. It seems like most people, when they want to make a game, the first thing they want to make is, you know, I want to make a grand open world procedurally generated in- like the you know the largest possible scope of a professional game um yeah but it kind of underscores one of the other big differences between making games by yourself or at an indie studio versus a triple a triple a studio which is just the quality requirements at a AAA studio are stratospheric relative to what you're doing by yourself. Just the level of polish that we as a studio
是的，没错。似乎大多数人，当他们想制作一个游戏时，他们想做的第一件事是，你知道，我想制作一个宏大的开放世界，程序化生成，像，你知道，专业游戏可能的最大范围。嗯，是的，但这在某种程度上强调了你自己制作游戏或在独立工作室与3A工作室制作游戏之间的另一个巨大差异，这仅仅是3A工作室的质量要求相对于你自己所做的事情是平流层级的。仅仅是我们作为一个工作室
put onto every aspect of production is way, way higher than any individual could hope to accomplish. You know, we'll just obsess over things like when the game transitions from a cinematic segment to an in-game segment, the IK on the elbows will pop a little bit. So you'll see a little shift in the character's elbows and knees when we shift from one camera to another. And we'll spend weeks trying to solve that kind of problem. But if you're making a game by yourself, it would be a foolish allocation of time to spend that much effort
投入到生产的每一个方面的打磨程度，都远高于任何个人所能达到的水平。你知道，我们会沉迷于这样的事情，比如当游戏从电影片段过渡到游戏内片段时，肘部的IK会弹跳一点。所以当你从一个摄像机切换到另一个摄像机时，你会看到角色的肘部和膝盖有一点偏移。我们会花几周时间试图解决那种问题。但如果你自己制作游戏，花那么多精力去解决那种问题将是一种愚蠢的时间分配。
fixing that kind of problem. Yeah, I think that's also because as a player, we all expect AAA games to actually have these kind of little details fixed. But when you're playing an indie game, well, you might be okay with a few things wrong here and there. Yeah, that's a good point. I think a lot of indie games are actually one of two things. Either they're sort of variations on other games
是的，我认为这也是因为作为玩家，我们都期望3A游戏确实能修复这些小细节。但当你玩独立游戏时，嗯，你可能对这里那里的一些小问题没意见。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我认为很多独立游戏实际上是两件事之一。要么它们是其他游戏的变体，
with like a clever, funny theme, or actually they're interesting stories where they could have survived as like a novel, which many novels are written by one person, maybe with an editor or two editors. And so it's a very compelling story. And they've kind of put a game on top of it. And so that those are the two things I think one one person, one or two people can do well. But, yeah, I mean, as soon as you start saying words like MMO, you're you're you're in trouble but i think also one of the recent developments with things like unity um which we had an episode about recently is uh it is more than just a game engine
带有聪明、有趣的主题，或者实际上它们是有趣的故事，它们本可以作为小说生存下来，许多小说是由一个人写的，也许有一位编辑或两位编辑。所以这是一个非常引人入胜的故事。他们已经在上面放了一个游戏。所以这就是我认为一个人，一两个人可以做好的两件事。但是，是的，我的意思是，一旦你开始说像MMO这样的词，你就，你就，你就陷入了麻烦。但我认为最近像Unity这样的事情的发展，我们最近有一集关于它的节目，呃，它不仅仅是一个游戏引擎，
that they're providing hobbyists but they're trying to provide a tool chain as well right stuff for managing assets and levels and that which before if you were trying to do that on your own would just be crazy but now if you're leveraging the work of other people in that infrastructure, even as an individual or a few people, you can try to do something more ambitious. Yeah, that leads right into our next question, which is, you know, obviously a lot of people know about Unity. I think two or three shows ago, we covered Unity. And so the question is why do studios still roll their own game engines? I mean, it seems like everyone should just be using Unity.
他们提供给业余爱好者，但他们也试图提供一个工具链，对吧？用于管理资产和关卡的东西，如果以前你试图自己做这些，那简直是疯了，但现在如果你在那个基础设施中利用其他人的工作，即使作为个人或几个人，你也可以尝试做一些更雄心勃勃的事情。是的，这直接引出了我们的下一个问题，那就是，你知道，显然很多人都知道Unity。我想两三期节目之前，我们介绍了Unity。所以问题是为什么工作室仍然要自己开发游戏引擎？我的意思是，看起来每个人都应该使用Unity。
Well, like that quickly, I would think about two different things. The first is that it all depends on the game you're making, how specific the needs you've got. I think one good example is Grand Theft Auto 5. I mean, if you were making Grand Theft Auto 5 with Unity, you would end up with a lot of problems.
嗯，就像那样，我会想到两件不同的事情。第一是这完全取决于你正在制作的游戏，你有什么样的特定需求。我认为一个很好的例子是《侠盗猎车手5》。我的意思是，如果你用Unity制作《侠盗猎车手5》，你最终会遇到很多问题。
Not just about the streaming, but also about the editor part. You will end up basically rewriting everything. So all the gain that you will have by taking this existing engine, well, you will lose it because you will have by taking this existing engine, well, you will lose it because you will have to change everything. The other thing is, since you are using this engine developed by someone else, let's say you need these features like
不仅仅是关于流媒体，还有关于编辑器部分。你最终基本上会重写一切。所以你通过采用这个现有引擎获得的所有收益，嗯，你都会失去它，因为你将不得不改变一切。另一件事是，既然你正在使用别人开发的这个引擎，假设你需要这些功能，比如
right now, and since you are buying this engine, you might not have the engine team to make it yourself. So you depend on that other company that is making this engine. So you will have to wait for them to implement it for you. And that's something you might not want because, well, you can't wait six months or one year in a production for a certain feature to be implemented. Also, you are kind of dependent on the license fees. Right now, Unity is free or almost free. Unreal Engine is also really cheap. But when you are in a AAA studio, those license fees can go up really quickly. Yeah, I think I have that.
现在，既然你正在购买这个引擎，你可能没有引擎团队来自己制作它。所以你依赖于正在制作这个引擎的另一家公司。所以你将不得不等待他们为你实现它。这是你可能不想要的，因为，嗯，你不能在生产中等待六个月或一年来实现某个功能。此外，你有点依赖许可费。现在，Unity是免费的或几乎免费的。虚幻引擎也非常便宜。但当你身处3A工作室时，这些许可费可能会很快上涨。是的，我想我有那个。
I ask myself the same question all the time. Why are we still able to compete given the just amazing quality of the engines you can buy off the shelf like Unity or Unreal or even the amazing quality that other larger multi-studio organizations like Ubisoft or other studios have access to. And it makes me sweat because the artists will come to me and they'll show me some YouTube video of this really slick tool that's built into Unreal 4 that makes it incredibly easy
我一直问自己同样的问题。鉴于你可以买到的现成引擎（如Unity或虚幻）的惊人质量，或者像育碧或其他工作室等其他大型多工作室组织所能获得的惊人质量，为什么我们仍然能够竞争？这让我出汗，因为艺术家会来找我，他们会给我看一些YouTube视频，展示这个内置在虚幻4中的非常流畅的工具，它使得构建着色器或将资产放入游戏变得非常容易，
to build shaders or drop assets into the game. And I know that the process we have internally for doing the same things is really hacked together and duct taped together. And it's kind of embarrassing to point at that and say, yeah, we're going to make games to compete with Unreal, but our tool set, in a lot of ways, doesn't have anywhere near that level of finish. So I think about that question a lot. And I think there's a couple answers I've come up with.
而且我知道我们在内部做同样事情的过程确实是拼凑在一起的，用胶带粘在一起的。指着那个说，是的，我们要制作游戏来与虚幻竞争，但我们的工具集在很多方面远没有达到那种完成度，这有点令人尴尬。所以我经常思考这个问题。我想我得出了几个答案。
I don't know if they're true, but the first one would be that when you take a tool like Unreal off the shelf, then you have the same starting point as every other studio that has Unreal or Unity. And 95% of all games fail. So you have to think hard about what is it that makes my game unique and what gives us our competitive advantage in this really competitive marketplace. And if you're using an off-the-shelf engine, it can be difficult to develop a competitive advantage
我不知道它们是否正确，但第一个是，当你从货架上拿走像虚幻这样的工具时，你就拥有了与所有其他拥有虚幻或Unity的工作室相同的起点。而95%的游戏都失败了。所以你必须认真思考是什么让我的游戏独一无二，以及在这个竞争激烈的市场中是什么给了我们竞争优势。如果你使用现成的引擎，开发竞争优势可能会很困难，
because you're always working with the same tools that everybody else has. So even though some aspects of our pipeline are duct taped together, when we decide that something is really important for our game, like if we want really smooth, buttery movement mechanics, or if we want really great character faces and emotion in our characters, we can devote a lot of engineering resources to that problem that people who are stuck with the tools that come with Unity or Unreal just can't devote because they can't crack open the covers and make those changes themselves. Or like Flo was talking about, they have to rely on a third party to provide those things for them.
因为你总是使用每个人都有的相同工具。所以即使我们管道的某些方面是用胶带粘在一起的，当我们决定某件事对我们的游戏非常重要时，比如如果我们想要非常平滑、黄油般的移动机制，或者如果我们想要角色有非常棒的面部表情和情感，我们可以投入大量的工程资源来解决这个问题，而那些被Unity或虚幻自带工具困住的人根本无法投入，因为他们无法自己打开盖子并进行这些更改。或者像Flo所说的那样，他们必须依赖第三方来为他们提供这些东西。
So even though 90% of the stuff you get out of one of those off-the-shelf tools is really slick and works really well. And you have to make do with the last 10%. If you roll your own engine, you get to decide exactly what you want for 100% of the engine. And it turns out that that last 10% of things is really, really important in delivering a game that can stand out from the marketplace and feel unique and be successful yeah one thing that's kind of interesting about games and i'm sure there are other fields like this i mean i guess movies or things like that but is you know if you look at say honda for example i mean honda has to do sort of variations to the car every year but at the end of the day like the car is largely the same from one year to the next and so they just sort of uh you know they have a product cycle but at the end of the
所以即使你从那些现成工具中得到的90%的东西确实非常流畅并且工作得很好。你必须凑合着用剩下的10%。如果你自己开发引擎，你可以决定引擎100%想要什么。事实证明，最后10%的事情对于交付一款能够在市场上脱颖而出、感觉独特并取得成功的游戏来说非常、非常重要。是的，关于游戏有一件有趣的事情，我相信还有其他领域也是这样，我的意思是我想电影之类的，但是你知道，如果你看看本田，例如，我的意思是本田每年都必须对汽车进行某种变体，但归根结底，汽车从一年到下一年在很大程度上是一样的，所以他们只是，你知道，他们有一个产品周期，但归根结底
day they know that they have brand loyalty and and things like that and they just know that a certain number of people are going to buy hondas and there might even be a segment of people who don't want the next honda to look different than the first one they just want to keep buying their honda right um but a game is different i mean if you released i mean if you went so far as to literally release the same game a year later no one would buy it like that doesn't even make sense right maybe what no i mean like literally like if you were to have literally the same game i am taking to the extreme right but and you were to discount the first game and leave the new game at the same price there's there's no reason right so the point is like the sports games right yeah sports games are really similar year to year like almost no
他们知道他们有品牌忠诚度之类的东西，他们只是知道一定数量的人会购买本田，甚至可能有一部分人不想让下一辆本田看起来与第一辆不同，他们只是想继续购买他们的本田，对吧？嗯，但游戏是不同的，我的意思是如果你发布，我的意思是如果你走得那么远，字面上在一年后发布同样的游戏，没有人会买它，这甚至没有意义，对吧？也许什么？不，我的意思是，字面上，就像如果你字面上拥有同样的游戏，我正在走向极端，对吧？如果你对第一款游戏打折，让新游戏保持同样的价格，没有理由，对吧？所以重点是，像体育游戏，对吧？是的，体育游戏年复一年非常相似，几乎没有
changes but the lineups are different so you want to play the most recent if you really follow soccer right you want the fifa lineups that are this year's lineup i would argue that the content is the lineup and and that's and changing that is significant i would argue that even though it's it's the code isn't changing that the game itself changes dramatically just because of the but anyways you're right that that's sort of a corner case but i feel like one thing that's interesting about games is that you have to sort of stay novel and you have to constantly be doing different things to you know entertain um i think that is is really fascinating i would imagine that probably goes into needing to roll your own game engine so that you can sort of diversify yourself yeah i think the one thing is that when when are using Unreal Engine or Unity, you cannot make assumptions.
变化，但阵容不同，所以如果你真的关注足球，你想玩最新的，对吧？你想要FIFA阵容，那是今年的阵容。我会争辩说内容就是阵容，而且改变这一点很重要。我会争辩说，即使代码没有改变，游戏本身也会因为，但无论如何，你是对的，那是一种极端情况。但我感觉关于游戏的一件有趣的事情是，你必须保持新颖，你必须不断地做不同的事情来，你知道，娱乐。嗯，我认为这真的很迷人。我想这可能涉及到需要自己开发游戏引擎，这样你就可以多样化自己。是的，我认为有一件事是，当你使用虚幻引擎或Unity时，你不能做假设。
So basically, those systems have to work for every different kind of games. But when you're making an open world game, you know you might not have like a 2D physics system really strong because you won't use it that much. But that's something, that's the kind of assumption that you cannot have when you're making Unity or Unreal. Also, yeah, the fact that you have your own engine lets you try a different thing and maybe in an easier way because of course you know your engine upside down, you made it yourself. So it might be easier to break everything in it, change stuff in it and to try new gameplays. Yeah, that makes sense.
所以基本上，这些系统必须适用于每一种不同的游戏。但当你制作开放世界游戏时，你知道你可能没有像2D物理系统那样强大的系统，因为你不会经常使用它。但这是你在制作Unity或虚幻时不能有的那种假设。此外，是的，你拥有自己的引擎这一事实让你尝试不同的事情，也许以一种更容易的方式，因为当然你对你的引擎了如指掌，你自己制作了它。所以打破它里面的一切，改变里面的东西并尝试新的游戏玩法可能会更容易。是的，这很有道理。
Cool. Were you going to say something, Dave? Oh, go ahead, Dave. I'm not sure. I can't remember what I was going to say, but I do think, like as a counterpoint to that, I think it's also worth saying that
酷。你要说什么吗，戴夫？哦，继续，戴夫。我不确定。我不记得我要说什么了，但我确实认为，作为对此的反驳，我认为值得说的是
I think the tools that are there, like Unity and Unreal are amazing tools. And if you're a smaller smaller scale developer or even if you are a big developer whose competitive advantage doesn't come from the kind of things that derive from building your own engine then those tools are amazing and you should embrace them and run with it i can think of you know several studios that are using those those tools and making incredible games. And so I wouldn't want to dissuade
我认为现有的工具，像Unity和虚幻，是惊人的工具。如果你是一个小规模的开发者，或者即使你是一个大开发者，其竞争优势不是来自构建自己的引擎所带来的那种东西，那么这些工具是惊人的，你应该拥抱它们并运行它。我可以想到，你知道，几个正在使用这些工具并制作令人难以置信的游戏的工作室。所以我不想劝阻
anybody who's listening to this podcast from taking an off-the-shelf product and just running with it, because those things are really great. I'm so excited that they're on the market now. I think that's the thing as engineers, programmers, that we tend to do sometimes is say, oh, you can't write a serious
任何听这个播客的人使用现成产品并直接运行它，因为这些东西真的很棒。我很高兴它们现在在市场上。我认为作为工程师、程序员，我们有时倾向于做的事情是说，哦，你不能用X东西编写严肃的
application game in thing X. And it like well maybe but you know it just depends on what you're trying to do and we talk about this a lot like with web frameworks is another example people say oh you know i don't know how to write a web app that scales to 10 million simultaneous users it's like well but that's not your initial problem. You know, your initial problem is to make it interesting for one user. And so what you do to get service for one user or 100 users or 1,000 users, you have more flexibility in what tool to use. And using a really sophisticated tool or rolling your own, you know, server,
应用程序游戏。这就像，嗯，也许吧，但你知道，这取决于你试图做什么。我们经常谈论这个，就像Web框架是另一个例子，人们说，哦，你知道，我不知道如何编写一个扩展到1000万并发用户的Web应用程序。这就像，嗯，但那不是你最初的问题。你知道，你最初的问题是让它对一个用户来说很有趣。所以你为了获得一个用户或100个用户或1000个用户的服务所做的事情，你在使用什么工具方面有更多的灵活性。而使用一个非常复杂的工具或自己开发，你知道，服务器，
you know, binaries and applications would actually just get you nowhere really fast because you would spend all your time doing that and you would never make your web app so you're saying that if Unity was around I would have been able to complete my civilization MMO procedural content game I was just born too early I think anyone who tried Unity
你知道，二进制文件和应用程序实际上会让你很快一事无成，因为你会把所有时间都花在那上面，而你永远不会制作你的Web应用程序。所以你是说如果Unity存在，我就能完成我的文明MMO程序化内容游戏了？我只是出生得太早了。我想任何尝试过Unity
and Unreal for like 10 minutes quickly understands that those are really, really powerful tools. And I think actually working at Epic Games or Unity on those editors and engines, even as a tools programmer, it's almost a different kind of job than working on your own level editor and engine in a AAA game studios because the level of details is not the same. I mean, we don't need this kind of generic systems. And this is also why Unreal and Unity are really powerful, because they can achieve this kind of level of details
和虚幻10分钟的人很快就会明白，那些是非常、非常强大的工具。而且我认为实际上在Epic Games或Unity工作在那些编辑器和引擎上，即使作为工具程序员，也几乎是一种与在3A游戏工作室工作在自己的关卡编辑器和引擎上不同的工作，因为细节水平是不一样的。我的意思是，我们不需要这种通用系统。这也是为什么虚幻和Unity非常强大，因为它们可以达到这种细节水平
and generic system. They are really impressive tools. Cool. So I would imagine several people in the audience, several people out there are students, as we talked about, but there are also a lot of people who work in just a variety of industries. We've seen sort of everything from petroleum engineers, someone who makes lightsabers for a living, all sorts of things. And so a lot of people don't know what it's like to sort of be a full-time, you know, programmer and specifically like in the game studio,
和通用系统。它们是非常令人印象深刻的工具。酷。所以我可以想象观众中的几个人，外面的一些人是学生，正如我们所谈到的，但也有很多人在各种行业工作。我们已经看到了从石油工程师，到以制作光剑为生的人，各种各样的事情。所以很多人不知道作为一名全职，你知道，程序员，特别是在游戏工作室里是什么感觉，
you know, day to day, what it's like, kind of what the atmosphere is like. So can you kind of like take us through sort of an average day in your role and what that kind of feels like? Well, as a tools programmer, the days are never the same, actually. As I said earlier, there is like no routine. So that's something I really like about it. It's never boring, basically. Basically, you know what you have like long-term tasks so that you do
你知道，每天，它是什么样的，那种氛围是什么样的。所以你能带我们了解一下你角色中的平均一天，以及那种感觉是什么样的吗？嗯，作为一名工具程序员，日子从来都不一样，实际上。正如我之前所说，没有常规。所以我真的很喜欢这一点。它基本上永远不会无聊。基本上，你知道你有什么长期任务，所以你
every day most of the times they come from the other teams like artists animators designers they need you to make some specific tools so they can work in a more efficient way but very often what happens is that someone comes to you with this this really blocking bugs, so they need you to fix it. So that's the no routine part of the job. So yeah, basically one morning you can come up and work on shaders, and then the next day you will work on the sequence editor,
每天做。大多数时候它们来自其他团队，比如艺术家、动画师、设计师，他们需要你制作一些特定的工具，这样他们才能以更有效的方式工作。但经常发生的是，有人带着这个非常阻碍性的错误来找你，所以他们需要你修复它。所以这就是工作中没有常规的部分。所以是的，基本上一个早上你可以起来处理着色器，然后第二天你将处理序列编辑器，
and then the next day you will work on something else. That's one of the really great part of the job. Yeah, I totally agree with that. I think unlike a lot of other roles, a lot of other programming roles in a game studio, you have a really large diversity of tasks as a game programmer, so there isn't a prototypical day. But I guess, I mean, the activities do break down along certain lines. You spend a lot of time, like Bo said, doing support.
然后第二天你将处理其他事情。这是工作中非常棒的一部分。是的，我完全同意这一点。我认为与游戏工作室中的许多其他角色、许多其他编程角色不同，作为游戏程序员，你有非常多样化的任务，所以没有原型的一天。但我猜，我的意思是，活动确实沿着某些路线分解。你花了很多时间，像Bo说的那样，做支持。
You know, an artist will call you and say, Maya is crashing on me or my shaders won't compile, and so you spend some time trying to figure out why that's happening, which is probably very similar to things that happen in any kind of programming discipline, not just game programming. And you spend a lot of time near the end of the production fighting, just fighting fires. Like something will go wrong and a bunch of assets will get corrupted and it's a little bit different than your typical support call in that it tends to be a crisis and you just
你知道，一位艺术家会打电话给你说，Maya在我这里崩溃了，或者我的着色器无法编译，所以你花了一些时间试图弄清楚为什么会发生这种情况，这可能与任何编程学科中发生的事情非常相似，不仅仅是游戏编程。而且你在生产结束时花了很多时间战斗，只是在救火。就像有些事情会出错，一堆资产会损坏，这与你典型的支持电话有点不同，因为它往往是一场危机，你只是
invest a lot of energy trying to recreate work or steer around a problem that you didn't anticipate until the last minute. I guess that is a big thing that's different from other programming disciplines when you're working in the game studio and that's that it's very cyclical. The beginning of a project right after you ship the game feels a lot different from the end of a project three months before you're ready to ship a game. I mean, at the end, you're working really long hours and everybody's kind of getting together to try and push the thing over the finish line, whereas at the beginning of the cycle, there's a lot more pontificating about the future and trying to decide about the
投入大量精力试图重建工作或绕过一个你在最后一刻才预料到的问题。我想这确实是与在游戏工作室工作时其他编程学科的一大不同之处，那就是它是非常周期性的。项目开始时，在你发布游戏后，感觉与项目结束时，在你准备发布游戏前三个月，感觉非常不同。我的意思是，最后，你工作时间很长，每个人都在一起努力把事情推过终点线，而在周期开始时，有更多的关于未来的高谈阔论，试图决定软件的
architectural directions of your software and that kind of thing. Yeah, I think working for a game studio is a lot like working for a software startup, which is what I did before I was a game programmer. So it tends to be very loose as opposed to the kind of bureaucratic or structured image that I have of other kinds of
架构方向之类的东西。是的，我认为为游戏工作室工作很像为软件初创公司工作，这是我在成为游戏程序员之前所做的。所以它往往非常宽松，而不是我心目中其他种类的
programming jobs. So not a lot of meetings is what you're saying? Yeah, I've almost no meetings. I have probably maybe five meetings a year. Oh, wow. I thought you were going to say a day. Yeah, I thought you were going to say a day. Yeah, I thought you were going to say a day too. Oh man, we have too many meetings. Yeah, I consider it for my job to not have many meetings relative to my previous job, but I have at least one or two a day. Yeah, definitely. It depends on what you call a meeting too, because I have a ton of just conversations.
编程工作的那种官僚或结构化形象。所以你是说没有很多会议？是的，我几乎没有会议。我一年可能有五次会议。哦，哇。我以为你要说一天。是的，我也以为你要说一天。是的，我也以为你要说一天。哦，天哪，我们有太多的会议了。是的，相对于我以前的工作，我把没有太多会议视为我的工作，但我每天至少有一两个。是的，绝对。这也取决于你所说的会议是什么，因为我有很多只是对话。
No, I mean meetings. People just naturally aggregate and talk about problems in the kitchen or by their desks but very few meetings and outlook in a conference room where you all sit around and write in your notebooks yeah i mean i'm just going through yeah i have on average three meetings a day oh man um cool, like, I would imagine, you know, a lot of people who work at a game studio are into games. And so I would imagine you guys have a pretty cool game room. We just got a ping pong table in our game room, and that was a big deal.
不，我是指会议。人们只是自然地聚集在一起，在厨房或办公桌旁谈论问题，但在会议室里，你们都坐在那里，在笔记本上写字的会议很少。是的，我的意思是，我只是在经历，是的，我平均每天有三次会议。哦，天哪，嗯，酷，就像，我可以想象，你知道，在游戏工作室工作的很多人都喜欢游戏。所以我可以想象你们有一个非常酷的游戏室。我们的游戏室里刚放了一张乒乓球桌，那是一件大事。
But I would imagine, you know, over there, you guys have a pretty cool setup with, like, couches and things like that to relax every now and then. Yeah, definitely. Well, you have access to all the video games you can imagine so you can even uh you can even take them home if you want uh so that's pretty cool uh do you want to play video games at the end of the day really uh i think since i'm working in the video game industry, I don't play so much anymore.
但我可以想象，你知道，在那边，你们有一个非常酷的设置，有沙发之类的东西，可以时不时地放松一下。是的，绝对。嗯，你可以访问你能想象到的所有视频游戏，所以你甚至可以，呃，如果你愿意，你甚至可以把它们带回家，所以这很酷。呃，你真的想在一天结束时玩视频游戏吗？呃，我想既然我在视频游戏行业工作，我就不再玩那么多了。
It's like seeing Mickey Mouse with his head off, right? As soon as you work at Disney and you see the Mickey Mouse with the head removed. The thing is, before being in the video game industry, I used to play almost all the games I could get my hands on. Right now, I'm more choosing the games I want to play to almost all the games I could get my hands on. And right now I'm kind of like more choosing the games I want to play. It's also maybe because of a lack of time. So I need to be more selective. But yeah, you have also a kitchen where you can spend some time. We have free candies.
就像看到米老鼠摘下头套一样，对吧？一旦你在迪士尼工作，你看到米老鼠摘下头套。问题是，在进入视频游戏行业之前，我过去几乎玩我能拿到的所有游戏。现在，我更多地选择我想玩的游戏，几乎玩我能拿到的所有游戏。现在我有点更选择我想玩的游戏。这也可能是因为缺乏时间。所以我需要更有选择性。但是，是的，你还有一个厨房，你可以在那里花点时间。我们有免费的糖果。
We have a lot of cool stuff. Table soccer. Cool. So we talked about seeing Mickey with his head off, and that kind of leads to the next question, which is you've seen different, you know, the games at different stages. You've seen the game on day one, and you've seen the game on, you know, day T-1.
我们有很多很酷的东西。桌上足球。酷。所以我们谈到了看到米老鼠摘下头套，这引出了下一个问题，那就是你已经在不同的阶段看到了游戏。你在第一天看到了游戏，你在，你知道，T-1天看到了游戏。
And so sort of what's that like uh you know playing the game that's half finished i mean i i found a picture in my head is you sort of drop stick figures because you don't have any artwork and then the game is just like uber comical you know kind of like goofy tragic comedy you have like stick figures falling over and things like that but sort of what is that like is that kind of fun or torture or is it you know what are the sort of experiences like playing sort of the game as it as it gets more and more polished yeah it's definitely fun uh the thing is sometimes you need like a huge imagination to just see what the game will be at the end uh especially like i remember when for sequences of the games
所以那种感觉是什么样的，呃，你知道，玩半成品游戏？我的意思是，我脑海中出现了一幅画面，你只是放下火柴人，因为你没有任何艺术品，然后游戏就像超级滑稽，你知道，有点像傻乎乎的悲喜剧，你有像火柴人摔倒之类的东西，但那种感觉是什么样的？那是有趣还是折磨，或者它是，你知道，随着游戏变得越来越精致，玩那种游戏是什么样的体验？是的，这绝对很有趣。呃，问题是有时你需要像巨大的想象力才能看到游戏最终会是什么样子，尤其是，我记得当为了游戏的序列
like when you don't have animations or you don't have the final textures and instead of seeing like this nice moves and animations all you see is just your character in T-pose moving around just being translated
就像当你没有动画或者你没有最终纹理时，你看到的不是这些漂亮的动作和动画，你看到的只是你的角色处于T姿势，四处移动，只是被平移
and with placeholders everywhere for sounds, for the backgrounds, for everything. Yeah, you're definitely sometimes a big imagination, but it's funny. But the thing is, as a tools programmer, I often play the game in debug. So it means I have everything, like the settings at the lowest possible because I need to debug the game so
并且到处都是声音、背景、一切的占位符。是的，你有时绝对需要巨大的想象力，但这很有趣。但问题是，作为工具程序员，我经常在调试中玩游戏。所以这意味着我拥有所有东西，比如尽可能低的设置，因为我需要调试游戏，所以
I'm often the last one to see the final quality of the game with the highest graphics and stuff yeah I love behind the scenes stuff I love watching DVD commentary and that kind of thing where you can see how
我经常是最后一个看到具有最高图形和东西的游戏最终质量的人。是的，我喜欢幕后花絮，我喜欢看DVD评论之类的东西，在那里你可以看到
something's put together so I really love that part at the beginning of a project where it's not exactly stick figures it's like the opposite of stick figures because Naughty Dog's an old studio so we have built up 30 years worth of assets and some of them look incredible. When you're starting a new
事情是如何组合在一起的，所以我真的很喜欢项目开始时的那部分，它不完全是火柴人，它就像火柴人的反面，因为顽皮狗是一个老工作室，所以我们已经积累了30年的资产，其中一些看起来令人难以置信。当你开始一个新的
game you throw away maybe 75% of what you had and you but you still have uh to some extent beautiful character models and some motion loops are really highly polished animation so you've got the opposite of a stick figure in that there's nathan drake and he's running around the world and he has perfect animation and he himself is rendered pretty well uh but everything around him is just gray boxes and uh you know stubbed in stuff um and so you really do have to use your imagination and in a lot of ways it's it's a lot of fun but it's also just terrifying because you're just
游戏时，你扔掉你拥有的75%，但你仍然有，在某种程度上，漂亮的角色模型和一些动作循环是真正高度打磨的动画，所以你拥有火柴人的反面，因为有内森·德雷克，他在世界各地奔跑，他有完美的动画，他自己渲染得也很好，但周围的一切只是灰色的盒子，呃，你知道，存根的东西。所以你确实必须使用你的想象力，在很多方面，这很有趣，但这也只是可怕的，因为你只是
seeing the enormous amount of work that's sitting in front of you. And I think here especially, I'm always shocked at how late things come together. I mean, even just weeks or, you know, a couple months before a product ships, I see things that to me are just really scary. Like, I'm not sure how we're going to pull it off. And it's a real testament to this studio that people always exceed my expectations, even though my expectations at this point are really high of the people I'm working with. But they always just come through
看到了摆在你面前的巨大工作量。而且我认为在这里，我总是对事情组合在一起的时间之晚感到震惊。我的意思是，即使在产品发布前几周或，你知道，几个月，我看到对我来说真的很可怕的事情。比如，我不确定我们将如何实现它。这个工作室确实证明了人们总是超出我的期望，尽管此时我对与我一起工作的人的期望确实很高。但他们总是挺过来
and do just amazing things in what seems like an impossibly short amount of time. So is it more that you'll have like a single level built up to an almost finished state before adding all the other levels? Or you have all the levels kind of start to play together, but in a really rudimentary state, and then they kind of all improve in lockstep, but you're playing the game end-to-end with kind of missing parts. Well, I guess it depends on the kind of game you're making. From my experience, everything goes up in parallel. Like every mission is built in parallel.
并在看起来短得不可思议的时间内做出了令人惊叹的事情。所以，是更多地在添加所有其他关卡之前，将单个关卡构建到几乎完成的状态？还是你让所有关卡开始以一种非常基础的状态一起玩，然后它们都同步改进，但你正在玩缺少部分的游戏？嗯，我想这取决于你正在制作的游戏类型。根据我的经验，一切都是并行上升的。就像每个任务都是并行构建的。
And the features, so when you well at the start of the production of course you don't have much but when you do something like a new feature it's supposed to work on every other level at the same time so yeah the content is supposed to be
还有功能，所以当你，嗯，在生产开始时，当然你没有太多东西，但当你做像新功能这样的事情时，它应该同时在每个其他关卡上工作，所以是的，内容应该是
more horizontal you know working throughout the game rather than doing specific to a level. Right. Yeah, that's actually, that's interesting. That's pretty different from the way we end up doing things. I think, I mean, at the beginning of the process, we end up with a large variety of different kinds of levels.
更水平的，你知道，在整个游戏中工作，而不是做特定于关卡的事情。对。是的，这实际上很有趣。这与我们最终做事的方式非常不同。我想，我的意思是，在过程开始时，我们最终会有各种各样的不同关卡。
You know, the designers will have cooked up a few levels to test out, or I wouldn't even really call them levels, but just environments to test out new game mechanics that they want to try, or just obstacles or puzzles that they think would be interesting. And at the same time, in pre-production, they've developed a narrative arc for the story,
你知道，设计师会准备几个关卡来测试，或者我甚至不会真正称它们为关卡，而只是环境来测试他们想尝试的新游戏机制，或者只是他们认为会很有趣的障碍或谜题。与此同时，在预生产中，他们已经为故事开发了一个叙事弧，
and some parts of that arc they may be confident will go into the game, and other parts they may think are going to require some tweaking so the parts that have more confidence end up going to production earlier so you'll see that stuff get put together early in the process but there's big chunks of the game that we may not even start working on so pretty late in the process we'll tend to do a vertical slice at some point where we try and come up with a section of the game that demonstrates all the gameplay
那个弧线的某些部分他们可能确信会进入游戏，而其他部分他们可能认为需要一些调整，所以更有信心的部分最终会更早进入生产，所以你会看到那些东西在过程早期就组合在一起，但游戏中有很大一部分我们甚至可能还没有开始工作，所以直到过程很晚，我们才会倾向于在某个时候做一个垂直切片，在那里我们尝试想出一个游戏部分，展示所有的游戏玩法
mechanics that we want, all the rendering features that we think we'll need, and we'll test out all the elements of the production pipeline that we expect to have at the end, and then we'll build that start to finish to a high level of polish just to validate that we're going down a path that we can
机制，我们认为我们需要的所有渲染功能，我们将测试我们期望在最后拥有的生产管道的所有元素，然后我们将从头到尾将其构建到高水平的打磨，只是为了验证我们正在走上一条我们可以
actually finish. And then from there, if things are successful, we'll make adjustments and start to bring other parts of the game to a greater level of polish. And then we just test like crazy. Every six weeks near the end of the project, we'll have focus testing where people will come in and play the game, and based on their feedback, we'll make changes and try to make it more fun and cut out stuff that's not
最终完成。然后在此基础上，如果一切顺利，我们会进行调整，并开始将游戏的其它部分打磨得更加精良。接着我们就会疯狂地进行测试。在项目接近尾声时，每六周我们都会进行一次焦点测试，让人们进来试玩游戏，并根据他们的反馈进行修改，努力让游戏变得更有趣，并删掉那些没用的东西。
working One thing is that I don't know at Naughty Dog but at Ubisoft we use a lot of test maps, I think you said that Dave that's something most of the people don't know is that when you
工作。有一点是，虽然我不了解顽皮狗（Naughty Dog），但在育碧（Ubisoft），我们使用大量的测试地图。我想你之前提过，戴夫（Dave），这是大多数人不知道的事情，就是当你
are for example implementing a new feature you won't test it directly into the final game. You will actually make a test map that is dedicated to that and everybody that someone is iterating on these new features, this will be the map that you will get to where you will test your features. And yeah, we're trying to do things in a modular way and then we put that in the final game so i heard stories actually i believe the stories came out of naughty dog studios but um there's stories about like the original crash bandicoot and how they had this crazy sort of uh monte carlo heuristic to pack things yeah we were talking
例如在实现一个新功能时，你不会直接在最终的游戏版本中进行测试。你实际上会制作一个专门用于该功能的测试地图，当有人在迭代这些新功能时，这就是他们用来测试功能的地图。是的，我们尝试以模块化的方式做事，然后将其放入最终的游戏中。我确实听过一些故事，我相信这些故事来自顽皮狗工作室，但嗯，有一些关于最初的《古惑狼》（Crash Bandicoot）的故事，以及他们如何使用那种疯狂的蒙特卡洛启发式算法来打包数据，是的，我们刚才在谈论
about that last episode yeah we talked about this last episode and so um you hear so much about this there's a there was an old game where um you had to shoot it was a star wars game for the atari 50 or atari 2600 where you just shot these horizontal lasers at this Death Star looking thing and there was a band in the middle of the screen where you were invulnerable but you also couldn't shoot and it didn't really make sense and then the game developer said yeah I couldn't fix this bug and so I just made it part of the game and so you just hear these stories of just this like it sounds very epic of just uh like amazing feats of engineering at very desperate moments and uh and i just wonder you know i haven't really kept up to date and so just with moore's law computers getting stronger more memory
关于上一集的内容，是的，我们在上一集谈到了这一点。所以，嗯，你听到了很多关于这方面的事情。曾经有一个老游戏，嗯，你必须射击，那是一款雅达利50或雅达利2600上的《星球大战》游戏，你只是向那个看起来像死星的东西射击水平激光，屏幕中间有一段区域你是无敌的，但你也无法射击，这真的说不通。然后游戏开发者说，是的，我无法修复这个漏洞，所以我只是把它变成了游戏的一部分。所以你总是听到这些故事，听起来非常史诗，就像在非常绝望的时刻展现了惊人的工程壮举。我只是想知道，你知道，我并没有真正跟上最新情况，所以随着摩尔定律，计算机变得更强大，内存更多，
things like that do you still have these sort of crazy moments where at the end you have to do something heroic to make the game work? Or is that kind of a relic? Yes and no. I think maybe not in tools, actually. Maybe if you ask the gameplay programmers, they might have this kind of story. But since I'm making tools, the tools I'm making are not shipped with the game. But yeah, since the deadline is often yesterday, you might, especially at the end of the game
诸如此类的事情，你是否仍然会有这种疯狂的时刻，在最后不得不做一些英雄般的事情来让游戏运行？还是说那已经是一种遗迹了？既是也不是。我想也许在工具方面不是这样。如果你问游戏玩法程序员，他们可能会有这样的故事。但因为我在制作工具，我制作的工具不会随游戏一起发布。但是，是的，由于截止日期通常是昨天，你可能会，特别是在游戏结束时，
when you are crunching, you might end up forgetting all your nice rules about how to write nice code and start to be efficient. Well, efficient, if you can call this efficient. But pushing stuff in the game, yeah. I don't have specific stories about it, though.
当你处于紧要关头（crunching）时，你可能会忘记所有关于如何编写漂亮代码的良好规则，开始追求效率。嗯，效率，如果你能称之为效率的话。但是把东西塞进游戏里，是的。不过我没有关于这方面的具体故事。
Yeah, it definitely happens. I'm trying to think of good examples that are good stories. Most of the examples I can think of aren't that sexy or just don't make great stories. Like I know that during the, near the end of one of our last projects we got within a couple weeks of having to print discs and send them off to the manufacturing to go into Best Buy and we still hadn't received something like 95%
是的，这种情况肯定会发生。我正在努力想一些好的例子，也就是好的故事。我能想到的大多数例子都不那么性感，或者只是构不成好的故事。比如我知道在我们的最后一个项目接近尾声时，距离必须打印光盘并将其发送到制造工厂以进入百思买（Best Buy）只剩下几周时间了，而我们仍然没有收到大约95%
of the translations for one of the languages, which would mean if we didn't get those into the game that would mean delaying production and delaying the ship of the translations for one of the languages which would mean if we didn't get those into the game that would mean uh delaying production and delaying the ship of the game and it would basically cost just tens or tens of millions of dollars probably for us to recover from that mistake so when you face the prospect of trying to chew through a hundred thousand audio files all within the last week of production and try and make sure that they all live up to our standards for quality. That can be pretty terrifying, but not necessarily that exciting. There's other bugs where I know our save games were getting corrupted after we shipped The Last of Us,
的某种语言的翻译，这意味着如果我们不能把它们放进游戏里，就意味着要推迟生产和推迟游戏的发布，这基本上会让我们损失数千万美元来弥补这个错误。所以当你面临试图在生产的最后一周内处理十万个音频文件，并确保它们都符合我们的质量标准时，那可能会非常可怕，但不一定那么令人兴奋。还有其他漏洞，我知道在我们发布《最后生还者》（The Last of Us）后，我们的存档文件出现了损坏，
so there was a pretty heroic effort to try and solve that as quickly as possible because it meant people were playing the game and then losing there and all of their progress after the first day. Yeah, stuff definitely happens, but I'm failing to come up with great examples to talk about. All right, cool. Yeah, it sounds, I mean, anything that's on sort of a product cycle. I believe, Patrick, your current task is on a product cycle. Is that correct or no? Somewhat. Yeah, Patrick, your current task is on a product cycle. Is that correct or no? Somewhat, yeah, yeah, yeah.
所以当时为了尽快解决这个问题，我们进行了相当英勇的努力，因为这意味着人们在玩游戏，然后在第一天之后就丢失了他们所有的进度。是的，事情确实会发生，但我没能想出什么好的例子来谈论。好的，酷。是的，听起来，我的意思是，任何处于某种产品周期的事情。我相信，帕特里克（Patrick），你目前的任务是在一个产品周期内。是这样吗，还是不是？有点。是的，帕特里克，你目前的任务是在一个产品周期内。是这样吗，还是不是？有点，是的，是的，是的。
Yeah, I mean, me as well. I'm rather new to it, but my current task has me on a product cycle. And it is pretty stressful, but it's also pretty awesome when you have such a tight deadline to sort of see what sort of innovative thing you can do to get you know the 80 the mythical 80 solution yeah i mean a lot of the stories end up being things for me is like there's some bug you can't find and you end up just trying to detect the thing that causes the bug and just like end around it like when you notice this happening uh just reset this other thing and then you you know just document it that like just do this it doesn't make sense yeah i mean i remember seeing some some issue in a video game might have been
是的，我的意思是，我也是。我对此比较陌生，但我目前的任务让我处于一个产品周期中。这确实压力很大，但当你有一个如此紧迫的截止日期时，看看你能做出什么样的创新来达到那个神话般的80%解决方案，也是非常棒的。是的，我的意思是，很多故事对我来说最终都是这样的：有一些你找不到的漏洞，你最终只是试图检测导致漏洞的东西，然后绕过它。比如当你注意到这种情况发生时，嗯，重置其他东西，然后你，你知道，只是记录下来，就像这样做就行了，虽然这说不通。是的，我的意思是，我记得在某个电子游戏中看到过一些问题，可能是
like zelda ocarina of time where some level crashed and in the end they just deleted that level and shipped it it's just like a funny thing but uh cool so um so it you know there's obviously you know there's a lot of people who are really into games, love what you guys are doing and want to become a game programmer. Many of the people that we talk to are, you know, in university or maybe going to university again or in high school or, you know, things like that. Definitely, like, you know, interested in learning. Those are people who kind of gravitate to the show and things like that. So for these kind of people, what sort of subjects should they study to become a good game programmer, tools programmer, etc.? Well, definitely computer science, of course, but mathematics like linear algebra, everything that is related to 3D.
像《塞尔达传说：时之笛》（Zelda Ocarina of Time）那样，某个关卡崩溃了，最后他们只是删除了那个关卡并发布了游戏，这只是件有趣的事情。但嗯，酷，所以嗯，你知道，显然有很多非常喜欢游戏的人，热爱你们所做的事情，并想成为一名游戏程序员。我们交谈过的许多人，你知道，在大学里，或者可能再次上大学，或者在高中，或者，你知道，诸如此类的事情。绝对是，就像，你知道，有兴趣学习。这些人往往会被这个节目所吸引。所以对于这些人，他们应该学习什么科目才能成为一名优秀的游戏程序员、工具程序员等？嗯，当然是计算机科学，当然，还有数学，比如线性代数，所有与3D相关的东西。
Even if you won't do that every day, like even if you're not a graphics engineer, when you will apply for a job in the video game industry, you can be sure that you will be asked questions about 3D. So you need to know your linear algebra. Also a bit about low-level architecture, like the machines, how they work, how the CPU works,
即使你不会每天都做这些，比如即使你不是图形工程师，当你申请视频游戏行业的职位时，你可以肯定会被问到关于3D的问题。所以你需要了解你的线性代数。还有一点关于底层架构的知识，比如机器，它们是如何工作的，CPU是如何工作的，
and in relation with the memory. Once again, even if it's not your everyday job, they're going to ask you to, and it's really useful sometimes when you need to optimize stuff. You also need a good demo or a good project, even if it's not related to video games, even if it's a tool, if it's a procedural,
以及与内存的关系。再一次，即使这不是你的日常工作，他们也会问你，而且当你需要优化东西时，这有时真的很有用。你还需要一个好的演示或一个好的项目，即使它与视频游戏无关，即使它是一个工具，如果它是程序化的，
if it's something generating stuff procedurally, whatever it is, have a good portfolio and good tools. Yeah, I agree with everything you said. Those are all, especially would want to underscore the need for strong math skills. I think that's something that differentiates game programming from other disciplines. There's more math required, especially linear algebra,
如果它是某种程序化生成东西的东西，无论它是什么，都要有一个好的作品集和好的工具。是的，我同意你所说的一切。这些都是，特别是我想强调对强大数学技能的需求。我认为这是区分游戏编程与其他学科的地方。需要更多的数学，特别是线性代数，
than you would encounter in traditional application programming. So if you're looking for a way to study for game programming as opposed to other fields, that would be something to spend a lot of time on. I'd also point out that at a high level, we as a studio, and I'm sure every other studio, are just desperate for qualified people. So if you want to get into the industry
比你在传统应用程序编程中遇到的要多。所以如果你正在寻找一种学习游戏编程的方法，而不是其他领域，那将是你需要花费大量时间的地方。我还想指出，在高层面上，我们作为一个工作室，我相信其他每个工作室，都非常渴望合格的人才。所以如果你想进入这个行业，
just do your best to become qualified and the studios will definitely want to uh to use your skills um some other things that i can think of that maybe wouldn't have been obvious to me uh on my road here like facing forward but looking back but there's a lot of projects that i worked on that i found especially educational um so I would just list a couple of those, like making your own OS, even if it's just a tiny one that does barely anything, is really valuable for teaching you the relationship between the computer hardware and the software that's running on it. Building a compiler is equally incredibly educational for teaching you what's going on behind the covers when you when you write your software writing a ray tracer is a really
尽你最大的努力变得合格，工作室肯定会想要使用你的技能。嗯，还有一些我能想到的，对我来说可能并不明显的事情，在我来到这里的路上，就像向前看但回顾过去一样。但我参与过的很多项目，我发现特别有教育意义。所以我只想列举其中几个，比如制作你自己的操作系统，即使它只是一个几乎什么都不做的微型系统，对于教你计算机硬件和运行在它上面的软件之间的关系也非常有价值。构建一个编译器对于教你当你编写软件时幕后发生了什么同样具有难以置信的教育意义。编写一个光线追踪器是一个非常
valuable thing to learn that 3d math and to learn graphics and it's surprisingly not that difficult like once you get into it it looks incredibly impenetrable when you start out but once you're done you will have learned a ton of stuff. It's incredibly valuable. And then, of course, just make games. Do whatever you can do that keeps you excited about making games, and those projects will lead you down a path that should be successful. That's funny that you talk about making a retracer for learning linear algebra
有价值的事情，可以学习3D数学和图形学，而且令人惊讶的是，它并不那么困难。一旦你进入其中，当你开始时，它看起来非常深不可测，但一旦你完成了，你就会学到很多东西。它非常有价值。然后，当然，只是制作游戏。做任何你能做的让你对制作游戏保持兴奋的事情，这些项目会引导你走上一条应该会成功的道路。你谈到为了学习线性代数而制作光线追踪器，这很有趣，
because that's exactly what I did actually when I was a student. I wanted to be fluent with matrices and stuff like that. So I thought what kind of project would allow me to learn this and I thought about a retracer. So that's exactly what I did. Yeah, it's true. It's really important to have educational project. And it will also help you if you want to do machine learning what's that so that's completely opposite learning about linear algebra and matrices
因为这正是我在学生时代所做的。我想熟练掌握矩阵之类的东西。所以我思考什么样的项目能让我学到这些，我想到了光线追踪器。所以这正是我所做的。是的，这是真的。拥有教育项目真的很重要。如果你想做机器学习，它也会对你有帮助。那是什么？所以这完全是相反的，学习线性代数和矩阵，
because that's the other thing it crops up all the time because i don't program games but only time i encounter math is when someone's done some machine learning something and then it's like oh there's the math now that it's hiding in one place in the project yeah that's interesting i mean i would have thought um that you would definitely want to do something practical you know in the sense that if you have to choose between linear algebra and you know networking you know you know ethernet networking i would imagine that the choice would be ethernet networking but i'm actually that the choice would be Ethernet networking, but I've actually proven wrong.
因为这是另一件事，它总是出现。因为我不编写游戏，但我遇到数学的唯一时间是当有人做了一些机器学习的东西时，然后就像，哦，数学现在出现了，它隐藏在项目的一个地方。是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，我本以为你会绝对想做一些实际的事情，你知道，从某种意义上说，如果你必须在线性代数和你知道的网络，你知道以太网网络之间做出选择，我想象选择会是以太网网络，但我实际上被证明是错的。
It sounds like having sort of a good theoretical computer science background is still really important for game development. Yeah, definitely. But it's not all theoretical. When I mean, for example, know your linear algebra, when you're making a retracer, it's, know your linear algebra. When you're making a retracer, it's not just a good algorithm. You're not sending to people a CPP file.
听起来拥有良好的理论计算机科学背景对于游戏开发仍然非常重要。是的，绝对是。但这并不全是理论。我的意思是，例如，了解你的线性代数，当你制作光线追踪器时，它不仅仅是一个好的算法。你不是发送给人们一个CPP文件。
It's actually a software that can generate pictures. And this is what you're going to send to people to apply for a job with all those nice pictures that you've made and all the techniques you were able to develop. But yeah, you're right in being pragmatic. Like if you're making a game demo, maybe try to reduce the scope rather than trying, as we said earlier, to do this open world MMO games that you will never finish anyway so yeah you definitely need to be to be practical in some ways
它实际上是一个可以生成图片的软件。这就是你要发送给人们去申请工作的东西，带着所有那些你制作的漂亮图片和你能够开发的技术。但是，是的，你在务实方面是对的。比如如果你正在制作一个游戏演示，也许尝试缩小范围，而不是像我们之前说的那样，去制作那种你无论如何都无法完成的开放世界MMO游戏。所以是的，你绝对需要在某些方面保持务实。
yeah I do think you're right that you might be using linear algebra more during the interview process than during your job if you're looking for a job like a network engineer and and consistent with what i was saying before about just becoming qualified and what you want to do if you really want to be a network engineer at a game studio then yeah i would just recommend learn ethernet in and out learn everything you can about networking and about how uh networking in games is applied and i think that would also be a perfect way to find your way into the industry and it's other industries too that have the kind of thing where you have to do stuff for the
是的，我确实认为你是对的，如果你正在寻找像网络工程师这样的工作，你可能在面试过程中使用线性代数的次数比在工作中更多。这与我之前说的关于变得合格以及你想做什么是一致的。如果你真的想成为游戏工作室的网络工程师，那么是的，我建议彻底学习以太网，学习你能学到的关于网络的一切，以及关于游戏中的网络是如何应用的。我认为这也将是进入这个行业的一种完美方式。而且其他行业也有这种你必须只为面试做某些事情的情况，就像你知道的，当我为我现在的公司面试时，我必须实现一个堆排序，就像自从我在公司工作以来，我从来没有实现过我自己的堆排序，有库可以为我做这些。但为了证明我拥有这些知识，对吧，这就是我为了通过面试所需要做的。是的，那是对的。沿着这些思路，这看起来有点明显，但实际上，这对我来说很令人惊讶，我不得不以困难的方式学到它。所以我将尽量让尽可能多的人免受这种痛苦。但了解游戏，我的意思是，我很久以前申请过一份工作，那不是游戏编程工作，但面试进行得很顺利，我觉得我可以回答技术问题之类的事情，在某个时候，
interview only sometimes like you know when I did interview for my current company I had to implement you know a heap sort and it's like since I've worked at the company I've never implemented my own heap sort there's libraries that do that for me. But to prove I had the knowledge, right, like that was what I needed to do to pass the interview. Yeah, that's right. And sort of along those lines, this seems kind of obvious, but it's actually, it was surprising to me, and I had to learn it the hard way. So I will try to spare as many people as possible. But know about games i mean i i applied for a job a long time ago and i wasn't it wasn't a game programming job but uh um the interview is going well i felt like i could answer the technical questions and things like that and at some point
有人问我关于公司产品的问题，而我唯一知道关于这家公司的事情就是我，你知道，创建了一个账户，因为你必须创建一个账户才能申请工作。结果那部分进行得非常糟糕，理应如此，因为我，你知道，事先没有对公司本身做任何研究，我只是想，哦，他们想要一个写代码的人，我可以写代码。但现实是，他们想要一个属于这里的人，他们觉得可以信任的人，并且感觉致力于该公司愿景的人。
someone was asking me questions kind of about the product of the company and uh the only thing i knew about the company was that I had, you know, created an account, because you have to create an account to apply for a job. And it ended up just kind of that part went very badly, as it should have, because I, you know, didn't sort of do any research beforehand on the company itself, I kind of just thought, oh, they want someone to write code, I can write code. But the reality is, they want someone who sort of belongs, who they feel like they can trust, and feels like is committed to that company's vision.
只找一个会写代码的人的问题在于，这有点像合同工，他们还不如外包出去。但如果他们雇佣你加入他们的公司，他们希望你加入他们的家庭。在这种情况下，这意味着了解游戏，了解该公司制作的游戏，了解他们的受众以及他们是如何工作的。
The problem with just getting someone who can code is that it's sort of like contract work they might as well outsource it but if they're hiring you to join their company they want you to join their family in this case that means understanding the games and understanding the games that company makes and what their audience is and how they work
你绝对需要激情，了解该公司制作的游戏，以及他们的受众和他们是如何工作的，诸如此类的事情。是的，无论如何你绝对需要激情。你知道，你经常听到那些疯狂的故事，关于某人仅仅因为，我不知道，他敲了门，里面有灯光，他进去了，然后就被雇佣了。但那可能是10、20年前的事了。现在制作游戏太复杂了，基本上全世界所有的工作室都在寻找非常强大的艺术家和非常强大的程序员。所以他们可以相当挑剔。所以是的，你需要技能，当然，
you definitely need passion that company makes and sort of what their audience is and how they work, things like that. Yeah, you definitely need passion anyway. You know, you often heard those crazy stories about someone who was hired just because, I don't know, he knocked on the door, there was light, he came in and then he got hired. But that was like maybe 10, 20 years ago. Now it's so complicated to make a game that basically all the studios in the world are looking for really strong artists and really strong programmers. So they can be quite selective. So yeah, you need skills, of course,
但了解游戏当然是强制性的。那么如果我在游戏中获得高分，那意味着我可以得到一份工作吗？实际上，也许在QA（质量保证）部门可能会有帮助，但对于其他事情，我不确定。
but knowing the games is of course mandatory so what if I have a high score in a game would that mean I can get a job? actually maybe to be in a QA that might help but for something else I'm not sure
我过去做过一些关于模拟器的工作，我做过很多关于模拟器的工作，有很多来自模拟器圈子的人。我不知道这听起来是否太时髦了，但有很多来自模拟器圈子的人去了游戏公司，游戏公司往往真的很喜欢这些人，因为他们知道他们喜欢游戏，而且他们可以做到底层的东西。所以我们总是谈论做开源，做开源，
I used to do some work on emulators, I have done a lot of work on emulators and there have been a lot of work on emulators and there have been a lot of people from sort of the emulator, I guess, scene. I don't know if that sounds too hipster, but there's been like a lot of people from the sort of the emulator scene who have gone to game companies and game companies tend to really like those people because they know they're into games and they can do sort of the low level bit of it. And so we always talk about do open source, do open source,
如果你想开始一个项目。虽然游戏，我们刚刚谈到了你自己制作一个游戏有多难，但有大量的开源项目是与游戏相关的，这可以给你非常好的经验。是的，绝对是。抱歉。我只是想说这绝对是真的。而且也很有趣。我的意思是，那些项目，制作你自己的游戏真的很有趣。所以你绝对必须有激情。就像你说的，我不认识这里任何不爱游戏的人，嗯，我想我认识几个人。我认识很少有不爱游戏的人，
if you want to get started on a project. And although games, we just talked about how hard it is to make a game by yourself, there's tons of open source projects that are games related and that can give you really great experience. Yeah, definitely. Sorry. I was just going to say that that's definitely true. And it's so much fun too. I mean, those projects are, it's so much fun to work on your own game. So you definitely have to be passionate. Like you were saying, I don't know anybody here who, well, I guess I know a few people. I know very few people who don't love games
并且自己玩很多游戏，因为如果你不爱它，你可能可以在不同的领域用更少的工作赚更多的钱。那你为什么要费心呢？但如果你真的喜欢它，这是一个很棒的地方。是的，绝对是。
and play them a lot on their own just because if you didn't love it, you probably could make more money for less work in a different field. So why would you bother? But if you do really enjoy it, it's a great place to be. Yeah, definitely.
我的意思是，很多事情是关于，你知道，我在Quora上回答了很多问题。Quora上的很多问题都是这种格式：我应该做X还是做Y才能得到最好的工作？好像这是一个某种优化问题。就像什么，我应该选CS101课程还是CS102课程，我才能去热门初创公司XYZ工作？现实是你应该只追随你的激情。如果你的激情是模拟器，那么你很有可能会做一些涉及那种细节水平的事情。
I mean, a lot of it is about, you know, I answer a lot of questions on Quora. And so many questions on Quora are of the format, should I do X or should I do Y to get the best job? As if it's like some kind of optimization problem. Like what, should I take course CS101 or CS102 I can go work at hot startup XYZ? And the reality is you should just follow your passion. And if your passion is emulators, then there's a high likelihood that you will do something that involves that kind of level of detail and things like that.
所以这也不例外。如果你发现你的激情是游戏，那么当你遇到紧要关头必须工作那些时间时，你会更容易协调。即使你见过米老鼠头掉了，你最终还是会因为沉浸在那种文化中而在一天结束时感到满足。我今晚睡觉时只会做噩梦。僵尸无头米老鼠。谢谢。僵尸无头。
And so this is no exception. If you find your passion is games, then you will have a much easier time when you do have that crunch time and you have to work those hours, you will have a much easier time reconciling that. And even if you've seen Mickey Mouse with his
抱歉，我打断了。有人要说些重要的事情。没有。没有。好的，酷。所以，是的，这太棒了。所以我们肯定会，你知道，正如戴夫所说，我相信弗洛伦特（Florent）也相信，你知道，顽皮狗和育碧分别绝对想要有才华的工程师、设计师、作家之类的人，所以我们肯定会从你们那里获取一个链接，并把它放在博客上，嗯，如果我假设
head off, you'll still sort of have satisfaction at the end of the day looking at the finished game because you've immersed yourself in that culture. I'm just going to have nightmares when I go to sleep tonight. Zombie headless Mickey Mouse. Thanks. Zombie headless.
你们有类似职业页面、工作页面的东西，所以我们肯定会给出链接，这样感兴趣的人就可以注册。是的，绝对是。我们有。如果你感兴趣且合格，就去申请。这就是我最终来到这里的方式。是的，绝对是。你们还有什么最后的评论吗？嗯，
Sorry, I interrupted. Someone was going to say something important. Nope. Nope. Okay, cool. So was going to say something important. Nope. Nope. Okay, cool. So, yeah, this is awesome. So we'll definitely, you know, as Dave said, and I'm sure as Florent also believes, you know, Naughty Dog and Ubisoft respectively definitely want to have talented, you know, engineers designers writers things like that and so we'll definitely we'll grab a link from you guys and put it on the uh on the blog um if i'm assuming
玩游戏。制作游戏。这很酷。是的，我同意这一点。我让它成为最后一个。好的，酷。是的，我会那样做。我让它成为最后一个。好的，酷。好吧，非常感谢你们来到节目。我们真的很感激。而且超级有趣。是的，外面的每个人，
you guys have something like careers page jobs page things like that and so we'll definitely give out the link so people are interested can sign up. Yeah, definitely. We do. If you're interested and qualified, go apply. That's exactly how I ended up here. Yeah, definitely. You guys have any last comments? Well,
一定要把你们的反馈发给我们。如果你有任何问题要问戴夫或弗洛伦特，我可以转达。你可以在Facebook或Google+上提问，我们可以确保它们被转到正确的人那里。关于节目本身的一点信息，关于节目的一点元信息，
play games. Make games. It's cool. Yeah, I'll agree with that. I'll let that be the final one. Alright's cool. Yeah, I'll do that. I'll let that be the final one. All right, cool. Well, thanks a lot for coming on the show. We really appreciate it. And super interesting. And yeah, everyone out there,
是我们确实设置了一个Patreon，所以我将把链接发出去。所以有人刚刚嗯向我们介绍了Patreon，或者我想是Patreon，这是一个网站，嗯你可以展示你的手艺，然后人们可以订阅它，他们也有某种捐赠，所以如果你嗯如果你对节目的书不感兴趣，但你仍然想支持节目，嗯你可以去这个Patreon网站，嗯并注册，我们确实已经有一些人这样做了，嗯我不知道你是怎么找到我们的，但这很酷，嗯我确实很感激，这绝对有助于保持我们的，我们有相当紧张的嗯托管成本，所以这确实在某种程度上帮助了我们。
definitely send us your feedback. If you have any questions for Dave or Floran, I can pass them over. You can just ask on Facebook or on Google+, and we can make sure they're routed to the right person and all of that. As far as one bit of information about the show itself, kind of a bit of meta information on the show,
所以我确实很感激，嗯谢谢你们所有的评论和你们所有的支持。好的，下次见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
is we do have a Patreon set up, and so I'll send out the link to that. So somebody just um introduced us to patreon it's or patreon i suppose it's this website where um you can sort of show your craft and then people can kind of subscribe to it and they also have sort of a donation so if you uh if you aren't interested in say the book of the show but you still want to support the show um you can go on this patreon site and uh and sign up and we do really some people have already done that um i don't know how you found us but that's cool um i do appreciate that and that definitely helps keep our we have pretty intense um hosting costs and so that does sort of help us out there
我们确实设立了一个Patreon页面，我会把链接发出来。有人向我们介绍了Patreon，我想应该叫Patreon吧，这是一个网站，你可以在上面展示你的作品，人们可以订阅，他们也提供捐赠功能。所以如果你对节目相关的书籍不感兴趣，但仍然想支持节目，你可以去这个Patreon网站注册。确实已经有一些人这样做了，我不知道你们是怎么找到我们的，但这很酷，我非常感激。这确实有助于维持我们的运营，我们的托管成本相当高，所以这确实对我们有帮助。
so i do appreciate it and uh thank you guys for all the the comments and for all the support you have. Alright till next time. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我非常感激，感谢大家所有的评论和支持。好了，下次见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown节目采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，也可以进行重混或改编，但必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。